ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव
यस आई थिंक आई एम लाइव ओके एवरीवन गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू
एक बार एक बार मुझे बता दीजिए सभी को
ऑडियो क्लियर जा रही है एंड विजिबिलिटी
सही है
प्लीज लेट मी नो फास्ट गाइस फास्ट हरी अप
हरी अप जल्दी करो जल्दी बता दो जल्दी बता
दो
गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते। नमस्ते।
नमस्ते। नमस्ते। गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते सभी
को। ओके।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सर मैं आपके सभी एसओसी के लेक्चर स्टार्ट
की हूं। लेक्चर वन एंड टू कर ली हूं।
जल्दी ही लेक्चर कंप्लीट करूंगा। बहुत
अच्छी बात है। आप जल्दी-जल्दी कर लीजिए
कंप्लीट। अच्छी बात है। ओके। सो आई होप कि
आप सब सुन पा रहे होंगे अच्छे से। सभी को
एक बार आ जाने देते हैं। देन वी विल बी
स्टार्टिंग वेरी सून। एंड लास्ट टाइम तो
लास्ट जो वीडियो थी उस पे बहुत जल्दी आप
लोगों ने 200 प्लस कमेंट्स कर दिए थे। तो
ये वीडियो जल्दी आ गई आपके लिए। अदरवाइज
आप जितना लेट करते उतना ही लेट फिर हमारे
साइड से होता आपके लिए। तो अच्छी बात है।
आप समझ रहे हैं उस चीज को एंड उस चीज को
सिंसियरली ले रहे हैं। इससे बड़ी चीज कुछ
नहीं हो सकती है। ओके। सो बिफोर वी
स्टार्ट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके।
आज का सेशन और भी खतरनाक होगा क्योंकि आप
आज के सेशन में आप सबकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी
और आप सबकी
जो है ना वो प्रेजेंस काफी जरूरी है।
क्योंकि आपकी प्रेजेंस के बिना आज का सेशन
होगा नहीं। पॉसिबल नहीं है। एंड आज हम
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग चीज करने वाले हैं। बट
उसके पहले मैं आपको पहले ही बता देता हूं।
फर्स्ट आई विल आई विल जस्ट लेट यू नो
फर्स्ट जस्ट अ सेकंड
हां जी ओके अभी 52 पीपल आर देयर सभी को आ
जाने देते हैं एक बार
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] देन देन ओनली वी
विल स्टार्ट राइट तो बिफोर स्टार्टिंग
फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल मैं आपको बता देता हूं कि हर
सेशन में हर सेशन में एक क्राइटेरिया है
कि उस सेशन के उस वीडियो के उस क्लास के
ऊपर 200 प्लस कमेंट्स अगर आप लोग कर पा
रहे हैं तो नेक्स्ट वीडियो आ जाएगी। ये एक
क्राइटेरिया लगाया है इस बार इस ट्रेनिंग
के लिए क्योंकि ये एक जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग
है। एंड दिस ट्रेनिंग डिर्व्स टू बी अ टू
बी प्रज़्ड और डिर्व्स टू बी नोटिस्ड एंड
डिर्व्स टू बी टेकन सिंसियर सिंस एंड
सिंसियरनेस आपकी होगी तो ही ये ट्रेनिंग
होगी। अदरवाइज ये ट्रेनिंग बीच में जब भी
सिंसियरनेस मुझे लगेगा नहीं है तो कंप्लीट
उसको खत्म कर दिया जाएगा या रोक दिया
जाएगा या पेड ओनली कर दिया जाएगा। तो इसकी
क्राइटेरिया ये है कि हर वीडियो पे 200
प्लस कमेंट्स अगर आप करते हैं यूनिक
कमेंट्स नॉट रिपीटेड कमेंट्स। लास्ट
वीडियो में कुछ लोगों ने क्या बहुत एक ही
एक ही बंदा बार-बार रिपीटेड कमेंट्स कर
करके 200 प्लस कर दिया बहुत जल्दी। बट
हमने जब काउंट किया तो रिपीटेड काफी सारे
निकले एंड यूनिक कमेंट्स 200 नहीं हुए थे।
तो जब 200 हुए तो बट हां काफी फास्ट हुए
कंपेरेटिव टू प्रीवियस क्लासेस। तो ये
अच्छी बात है। आपके अंदर थोड़ी सी जोश
होनी चाहिए। तो यूनिक कमेंट्स 200 प्लस
जैसे ही होंगे आपके लिए नेक्स्ट क्लास आ
जाएंगी। चलिए एंड सबसे पहले आपको काम क्या
करना है? जब भी आप क्लासेस देखते हैं अगर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आपने ये काम
नहीं करा है तो किसी भी डेफ्रोनिक्स एकडमी
YouTube चैनल पे जाके किसी भी लाइव सेक्शन
में जाइएगा। तो किसी भी एसओसी वाले क्लास
को ओपन कर लीजिएगा। एंड यहां पे आपको
डिस्क्रिप्शन को एक्सपेंड करना है। एंड
यहां पे आपको दो लिंक्स मिलेंगे। एक
WhatsApp ग्रुप का जो कि एसओसी का स्पेशल
ग्रुप है। इसको जरूर जॉइ करना है सभी
लोगों को क्योंकि एसओसी इस ट्रेनिंग के
रिगार्डिंग जितने भी रिसोर्सेज हैं, नोट्स
हैं या जो भी डिटेल्स हैं वो इसी ग्रुप
में सबसे पहले शेयर होंगी। एंड अपकमिंग
इससे इसके रिलेटेड कोई टेस्ट होगा जब
इंटरव्यूज के रिलेटेड कुछ होगा या
सर्टिफिकेशन के रिलेटेड कुछ इसके होगा तो
सब कुछ इसी में आपको आएगा। तो ये जरूर
आपको ज्वाइन करना है। दूसरे आपके WhatsApp
चैनल का एक लिंक मिलेगा जो कि डेफ्रोनिक्स
एकडमी WhatsApp चैनल है। इसको जरूर फॉलो
कर लीजिएगा क्योंकि एसओसी के अलावा और भी
जो भी इनफो या एसओसी की ही इनफो हम अगर
कंसीडर करें तो उसकी भी बहुत सारी इनफो
आपको इस चैनल पे मिलेगी। तो ये चैनल जरूर
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट
आपको दोनों चैनल दोनों ग्रुप्स में भी जॉइ
करना है और यह भी सब फ्री है। ठीक है?
उसके बाद Lindin पे आप मुझे यहां पे आके
मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। मुझे फॉलो अप
कर सकते हैं। यह मेरी प्रोफाइल है यहां
पे। एंड Lindin पे ही आप सर्च करेंगे
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स तो आपको डेfronic साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का हमारा Lindin का कंपनी का
पेज मिल जाएगा। आप इसको फॉलो जरूर कर
लीजिएगा। यहां पे 22,000 के आसपास
डेफ़्रोनिकर्स हमसे जुड़े हुए हैं। यहां पे
आप हमारी कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग जो भी
अपडेट्स हैं, जो भी हम किस तरीके से हमारे
स्टार्टअप को धीरे-धीरे आगे बढ़ा रहे हैं,
सब कुछ ए टू जेड आपको यहां पे
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन मिल जाएगी। यह हमारी कंपनी
का एक्स पेज है डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल
के साथ। आप इसको जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा।
यहां पे फ़दर आपको डिटेल्स फर्दर कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें आने वाली हैं। वो आपको
मिलती रहेंगी। यह हमारा Instagram पेज है
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल के साथ। यहां
आपको इनफेटिव रील्स एंड कंटेंट्स मिल
जाएंगे। ये हमारी वेबसाइट है। जहां पे आके
आप एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं वेबसाइट को।
एकडमी पे जाके हमारे डिफरेंट लिस्टेड
कोर्सर्सेस को एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। और
यह हमारा नंबर है जहां पे आप हमसे
कांटेक्ट करके कोई भी क्वेश्चन या किसी भी
तरह की क्वेरी हो आप हमसे कर सकते हैं। ये
सारी चीजें हो चुकी है। एक चीज और है जब
भी आप वीडियोस देखते हैं तो वीडियोस के
नीचे में वहां पे एक सेक्शन में आता है
हाइप करने का वीडियोस को। आप सबको पता है
कि आप ऐसे आपको दिखता है वहां पे। वीडियोस
को हाइप करने का ऑप्शन आता है। वह ऑप्शन
उस पे टिक करके हाइप कर दिया कीजिएगा।
उससे वीडियोस की रैंकिंग अच्छी होती है।
एंड YouTube रिकमेंडेशन जो है उस हाइप के
बेसिस पे काम करता है। आज के टाइम में
काफी ज्यादा प्रमोट कर रहा है ऐसी वीडियोस
को जिनके अच्छे हाइप्स हैं। तो आप हाइप कर
दीजिएगा तो उससे हमारा ही सपोर्ट होगा।
राइट? चलिए अब ये सब काम तो आप कर
लीजिएगा। मेरा जो काम है मैं शुरू कर देता
हूं। यह आपका काम है आप अपना करते रहिएगा।
मेरा काम है आपको ट्रेनिंग देना। मेरा काम
है आपको एक गाइडलाइन देना। मेरा काम है
आपको सही रास्ते पे लेकर जाना। एंड जो भी
कंटेंट प्रोवाइड करना वो क्वालिटी के साथ
प्रोवाइड करना। सो दैट यू गेट टू अ नो द
एक्चुअल थिंग्स नॉट द अ रबिश थिंग्स जो
इंटरनेट पे आपको कहीं-कहीं मिल जाती है।
तो आज इस सेशन में मैंने आपको जैसे कि
पहले ही बोला था सभी से बोला था। राइट? आज
इस सेशन में
हां नेटवर्किंग कांसेप्ट की भी आएगी भाई।
टाइम आने पे सब आएगा। देखो टाइम आने पे सब
आएगा। बस वेट करो और जैसे-जैसे मैं करा
रहा हूं करते जाओ।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आज इस सेशन में मैंने पहले ही बोला था कि
हम इंटरव्यू्यूज
के पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन
के पॉइंट ऑफ व्यू से यह सेशन कंडक्ट कर
रहे हैं। अभी तक टोटल कितनी क्लासेस हो गई
हैं आप सबको पता है। राइट? अभी तक अगर मैं
आपको दिखाऊं मैं अगर YouTube ओपन करता
हूं।
सो टिल नाउ एसओसी के प्लेलिस्ट आप
प्लेलिस्ट में जाएंगे एंड यहां एसओसी की
व्यू फुल प्लेलिस्ट करेंगे। तो अभी तक 10
क्लासेस हो चुकी थी। आज की जो क्लासेस हैं
ये 11वीं क्लास है। राइट? 11th क्लास। 10
क्लासेस में हमने यहां पे सबसे स्टार्टिंग
से इंट्रोडक्शन एंडेंस ऑफ एसोसिए ब्लूटिम
का देखा था। देन ह्यूमन अटैक वेक्टर्स
प्रोसेस टेक्नोलॉजीस देखे थे। सिस्टम अटैक
वेक्टर्स एंड वलेबिलिटीज़ देखे थे। अलर्ट
ट्रायग टीटीपीस, थ्रेट आईओसीस देखे थे।
देन अलर्ट [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
रिपोर्टिंग, एस्केलेशन, साइबर किल चेन ये
सब देखा था। देन मैलवेयर्स के बारे में
समझा था। फिशिंग एंड सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के
बारे में समझा था। पासवर्ड एंड
क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग के बारे में समझा था।
हैशिंग, शॉल्टिंग एंड इंक्रिप्शन के बारे
में समझा था। एंड देन लेटरल मूवमेंट एंड
प्रिविलेज एस्क्लेशन के बारे में समझा था।
तो इन 10 क्लासेस के बेसिस पे मैं यहां पे
आप सबके लिए आज का इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन
मॉडल जो है वो एग्जीक्यूट कर रहा हूं। एंड
इसमें जो क्वेश्चंस है इसके आंसर आप सब ही
करेंगे। ठीक है? मैं यहां पे मोबाइल
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] फोन पे मैंने
यहां पे रखा हुआ है। अ मोबाइल फोन का
स्क्रीन भी है मेरे सामने जहां पे मैं
आपके चैट्स देख पा रहा हूं सभी लोगों के।
एंड जितने भी लोग हैं लाइक ठोक देना फटाफट
एकदम से याद से। एंड आपके आंसर्स मैं
देखूंगा। यहां पे मैं आपको जज नहीं करने
वाला कि आप मतलब किस लेवल पे हैं। यह आप
खुद जज करेंगे अपने आपको। अब क्यों क्या
जज करेंगे अपने आपको? मैं आपको बताता हूं।
जैसे मैं आपसे क्वेश्चन करूंगा। उसका
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आंसर आपको देना
है। मैं देखूंगा कितने लोग आंसर कर रहे
हैं। अब इंडिविजुअली सबको
कुछ रिप्लाई करना तो पॉसिबल है नहीं। तो
आपको अपना आंसर करना है। जो भी आपके मन
में आंसर आ रहा है वो करना है। यहां पे
चैट बॉक्स में रेडी हो जाइए। बिल्कुल अपने
आप को एकदम प्रिपेयर कर लीजिए आंसर्स करने
के लिए। एंड उन आंसर्स के बेसिस पे मैं
यहां पे बताऊंगा कि करेक्ट आंसर कितने
लोगों का था। और उसकी एक्सप्लेनेशन आपके
साथ मैं शेयर करूंगा कि एग्जैक्टली क्या
है? इसका मतलब आंसर क्या है, क्यों है? ये
सारी चीज़। तो इससे आपकी एक प्रिपरेशन होगी
अच्छी खासी एंड एक रिकैप भी होगा एंड
इंटरव्यूज के टाइम कुछ इसी तरीके से आपको
आंसर करना है। कुछ इसी तरह के जब आपसे
क्वेश्चन करा जाएगा तो ऐसे आंसर्स होते
हैं। तो इसका आपको ध्यान रखना है। राइट?
सो आई थिंक यू ऑल आर रेडी। सभी लोग रेडी
हैं। मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए फटाफट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एवरीवन रेडी प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
आई थिंक आप रेडी हैं। ठीक है? चलिए। सो
नाउ नाउ लेट्स स्टार्ट। लेट्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] स्टार्ट। याद
रखिए जो लोग पहले आंसर करेंगे बिना मेरे
क्वेश्चन करे उनको मैं टाइम आउट कर दूंगा
एंड दे कैन नॉट आंसर। सो अभी एकदम रुक
जाइए सभी लोग। आंसर करने से अभी कोई भी
कुछ भी आंसर नहीं करेगा। अगर आप लोग अभी
भी आंसर करेंगे जो भी आंसर करेंगे अभी आई
विल पुट देम इन टाइम आउट। दे कैन नॉट आंसर
एंड दे कैन नॉट सेंड एनीथिंग इन द चैट। तो
मैं अभी आपको अगेन वार्न कर रहा हूं। अगेन
आई एम वार्निंग
चलिए अब इसके बाद से जिसका भी आंसर आएगा
उनका टाइम आउट कर देंगे 24 आवर्स के लिए
तो वो पूरे लाइव में आंसर नहीं कर पाएंगे।
राइट? सो
ओके
लेट्स सी
ओके शेखर शेखर इन बोलने के बाद भी
इन्होंने ये आंसर कर रहे हैं। सो शेखर
प्लीज डोंट गेट टाइम आउट।
चलिए रोहित पांडे को टाइम आउट कर देते
हैं। इनको टाइम आउट कर देते हैं 24 घंटे
के लिए। चलिए इनका टाइम आउट हो चुका है।
नाउ लेट्स सी इफ समवन एल्स इज पुटिंग
आंसर। कोई और भी आंसर दे रहा है तो उनको
भी टाइम आउट कर देते हैं।
ठीक है? नो वन इज़ आंसरिंग नाउ। लेट्स से
लेट्स स्टार्ट। चलिए स्टार्ट करते हैं।
फाइनेंस को हम इनको भी टाइम आउट कर देते
हैं 24 घंटे के लिए।
ओके ओके लेट्स स्टार्ट।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
सो
फर्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज व्हाट इज द प्राइमरी
रोल ऑफ एसओसी एल1 एनालिस्ट? आंसर वन ए है
डेवलप मालवेयर मॉनिटर अलर्ट्स एंड परफॉर्म
इनिशियल ट्राइब राइट सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसीज़
एंड द डी इज़ परफॉर्म पेंट्रेशन टेस्टिंग।
सो आप सभी लोग आंसर इसका कीजिए। लेट्स सी
हाउ मेनी ऑफ़ यू आर आंसरिंग करेक्टली।
सो, व्हाट इज़ द प्राइमरी रोल? प्राइमरी
रोल क्या होता है एसओसी एल1 एनालिस्ट का?
मैलवेस को डेवलप करना होता है प्राइमरी
रोल या अलर्ट्स को मॉनिटर करना और
परफॉर्म इनिशियल ट्रैग का होता है या
सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसीज को राइट करना होता है
या परफॉर्म पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग ऑब्वियस
सी बात है इसका आंसर बहुत सिंपल है इट्स
आंसर इज़ बी जो एसोसिएल एनालिस्ट होते हैं
वो अलर्ट्स को मॉनिटर करते हैं एंड
इनिशियल ट्रायग को परफॉर्म करते हैं। दिस
इज़ द दिस इज़ द आंसर जो कि बी आपका आंसर
है। बहुत सिंपल क्वेश्चन था। एंड यहां पे
मैं आपको एक आंसर शीट भी मैंने ओपन करके
रखा है। मैं इसको थोड़ा सा ज़ूम कर देता
हूं। एंड यहां पे आपके यहां पे आंसर्स भी
यहां पे देखते हम चलेंगे। हालांकि कुछ
बेसिक से वो है। स्टिल चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके।
सेकंड क्वेश्चन की तरफ आते हैं। व्हिच
मैलवेयर इंक्रिप्ट्स फाइल्स एंड डिमांड्स
पेमेंट्स? कौन सा मैलवेयर है जो फाइल को
इंक्रिप्ट करता है और पेमेंट डिमांड करता
है? सो फर्स्ट फर्स्ट ऑप्शन इज़ ट्रोजन,
वॉर्म, रैंसमवेयर और स्पाईवेयर। तो ए है
ट्रोजन, बी है वार्म, तीन है रैंसमवेयर,
चार है स्पाईवेयर। सो, व्हाट इज़ द आंसर?
इसका आंसर काफी लोग करेक्टली दे रहे हैं।
प्लीज आंसर वंस एक बार ही आंसर कीजिए।
मल्टीपल टाइम्स आंसर को मत सेंड कीजिए।
उससे कोई फायदा नहीं है। वो स्पैम लगता
है। राइट? ओके। ग्रेट। सो आंसर इज़ ये बहुत
इजी ये भी काफी इजी था कि ऐसा कौन सा
मैलवेयर है जो इंक्रिप्ट करता है फाइल को
डिमांड करता है पेमेंट तो ये रैंसमवेयर
होती है ट्रोजन वार्म स्पाईवेयर नहीं होते
हैं तीसरे क्वेश्चन पे आते हैं द थर्ड
क्वेश्चन इज़ व्हिच अटैक यूसेस वन पासवर्ड
अक्रॉस मेनी अकाउंट्स एक पासवर्ड अक्रॉस
मेनी अकाउंट्स व्हिच अटैक यूसेस वन
पासवर्ड अक्रॉस मेनी अकाउंट्स ब्रूटफोर्स
अटैक डिक्शनरी अटैक पासवर्ड स्प्रेइंग
अटैक या क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग अटैक अटैक
इसका बताइए क्या कौन सा ऑप्शन होगा? व्हिच
अटैक यूसेज वन पासवर्ड अक्रॉस मेनी
अकाउंट्स? बताइए।
सो ओके। सो द आंसर कमिंग इज़ सी।
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल सही आंसर है।
बिल्कुल सही आंसर है। आंसर शीट में भी
चलते हैं यहां पे। यहां पे यहां पे आंसर
इज़ सी। अ इसका रीजन यहां पे आपको ऑलरेडी
पता है। मैंने कांसेप्ट आपको बताया हुआ था
कि पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग ट्राइस वन कॉमन
पासवर्ड अक्रॉस मेनी यूज़र्स टू अवॉयड
लॉकआउट्स। तो ये आंसर भी मैंने आपको पहले
ही क्लियर देखो ये सब चीजें जो है पहले ही
मैंने क्लियर करा हुआ है। पहले ही आपको
कंसेप्ट्स बताएं हैं। तो आपको इनका आंसर्स
क्लियरली आना चाहिए। इसमें कोई कंफ्यूजन
आपके पास बिल्कुल नहीं होना चाहिए। चलिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ओके। अच्छी
बात है। काफी लोगों ने सी बोला है। गुड
गुड गुड टू नो। व्हाट डस हैशिंग प्राइमरली
प्रोवाइड? हैशिंग प्राइमरली क्या प्रोवाइड
करता है? कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी, इंटीग्रिटी,
ऑथेंटिकेशन और अवेलेबिलिटी? इसका आंसर
बताइए। हैशिंग प्राइमरली क्या प्रोवाइड
करता है? ए, बी, सी और डी?
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी, इंटीग्रिटी, ऑथेंटिकेशन
और अवेलेबिलिटी। बताइए।
यहां पे क्वेश्चन फोर का बी बोल रहे हैं।
कुछ लोग सी भी बोल रहे हैं। मैक्सिमम लोग
बी बोल रहे हैं। कुछ लोग सी बोल रहे हैं।
हैशिंग
क्या प्रोवाइड करता है? ऑब्वियस सी बात
है। हैशिंग जो हम करते हैं जनरली जब हम
पासवर्ड या किसी डाटा की करते हैं तो वह
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को डिनोट नहीं करता है।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है। वो कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी
डिनोट करने के लिए इंक्रिप्शन बना हुआ है।
ऑथेंटिकेशन का कोई मतलब नहीं है यहां पे।
एंड अवेलेबिलिटी का कोई मतलब है। तो यहां
पे इंटीग्रिटी का मतलब है डेटा चेंज नहीं
हुआ है बीच में कोई। किसी भी तरह का
मॉडिफिकेशन डेटा में नहीं हुआ है। किसी भी
तरह की कोई चेंजेस अन चेंजेस नहीं हुए
हैं। तो वो प्रोवाइड करता है आपका हैशिंग।
तो यहां पे जब आपसे क्वेश्चन ऐसा पूछा
जाएगा व्हाट डज़ हैशिंग प्राइमरली
प्रोवाइड? तो आपको इंटरव्यू के टाइम में
आपको बोलना है इंटीग्रिटी। इंटरव्यूज में
आपको ऑप्शंस नहीं देंगे। पहले ही मैं बता
रहा हूं। आई [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एम जस्ट सेइंग यू कि इंटरव्यूज़ में आपको
आंसर्स नहीं देंगे। मैंने यहां पे
एमसीक्यू टाइप इसलिए रखा है ताकि आपको ईज़ी
हो और आप दो तीन चीज़ों में चार चीज़ों में
कंफ्यूज़ ना हो। एंड दोनों तीनों चारों
चीज़ों में डिफरेंस आपको समझ में आ जाए कि
हां अगर सामने वाला पूछ दे कि क्या क्या
है
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को प्रमोट करता है? या
ऐसा पूछ सकता है क्या हैशिंग ऑथेंटिकेशन
को प्रमोट करता है या इंटीग्रिटी को? तो
आपको इंटीग्रिटी बोलना है। तो अगेन यहां
पे सेम आंसर गोज़ फॉर इंटीग्रिटी। हैशिंग
इंश्योरर्स इंटीग्रिटी बाय प्रोड्यूसिंग अ
यूनिक फिंगरप्रिंट ऑफ डाटा। यूनिक
फिंगरप्रिंट ऑफ डाटा को प्रमोट करके यह
क्या करता है? आपका हैशिंग जो है
इंटीग्रिटी को प्रमोट करता है। यूनिक
फिंगरप्रिंट आपको प्रोवाइड करता है डेटा
का। ठीक है? तो ये हो जाएगी इसकी आंसर जो
है वो है इंटीग्रिटी। तो कई लोगों ने बी
आंसर करा है उनका बिल्कुल सही है। जिन
लोगों ने सी करा था तो वो थोड़े से कंफ्यूज
थे। मुझे पता है किस बात को लेके थे। सी
जो भी जिन लोगों ने भी सी आंसर करा था वो
कंफ्यूज्ड इसलिए थे क्योंकि हैशिंग
पासवर्ड्स वगैरह में यूज में लिया जाता है
एंड ऑथेंटिकेशन का काम होता है पासवर्ड्स
का तो दे गॉट कंफ्यूज्ड ऑफ दीज़ ऑप्शंस तो
उन्होंने ऑथेंटिकेशन चूज़ कर लिया राइट यही
कंस यही रीज़न था आपका चूज़ करने का सी बट
यहां पे बात हो रही है हैशिंग प्राइमरली
किसको क्या प्रोवाइड करता है यहां पे
ऑथेंटिकेशन जो है इसमें ऑब्वियस सी बात है
इट हेल्प्स इन ऑथेंटिकेशन इट इज़ यूज्ड इन
ऑथेंटिकेशन। एकदम सही बात है। जो हैशिंग
होती है वो ऑथेंटिकेशन में होती है। यूज़
में आती है। क्योंकि पासवर्ड्स जो होते
हैं वो हैशड्ड होते हैं और पासवर्ड्स आर
यूज़्ड फॉर ऑथेंटिकेशन। बट यहां प्राइमरी
अगर आपसे पूछा देखो इंटरव्यू में यही काम
होता है। मैं आपको इसीलिए बार-बार बोल रहा
हूं कि इंटरव्यू में ट्रिकीज़ ट्रिक्स होते
हैं। इंटरव्यूज में आपको ट्रिक करने की
कोशिश की जाएगी। अगर आप ट्रिक हो गए तो
फिर आप वहां पे आपके माइनस पॉइंट हो गए।
ट्रिक नहीं हुए तो आपको वहां पे प्लस
पॉइंट मिल जाएंगे। तो यहां पे जब
प्राइमरली पूछा जाएगा ना कि भाई इनका
प्राइमरी काम क्या है? हैशिंग का तो
इंटीग्रिटी टू प्रोवाइड द इंटीग्रिटी।
दैट्स इट। एज सिंपल एज दैट। समझ में आया?
हां हां ठीक है। ये समझ में आ गया? चलो।
अब यहां पे क्वेश्चन है व्हाट डज सॉल्टिंग
प्रिवेंट? सॉल्टिंग किस चीज से प्रिवेंट
करता है? ब्रूटफोर्स अटैक्स, रेनबो टेबल
अटैक्स, फिशिंग या डीडीओएस? ए, बी, सी और
डी? प्लीज लेट मी नो जल्दी। फटाफट बताइए।
व्हाट डस साल्टिंग प्रिवेंट?
द आंसर इज़ द ऑप्शंस कमिंग फ्रॉम यू गाइस
आर मोस्टली रेनबो टेबल अटैक।
मोस्टली रेनबो टेबल अटैक। बिल्कुल। अब
इसका एक्सप्लेनेशन थोड़ा सा देख लेते हैं।
रेनबो टेबल अटैक क्यों? सॉल्टिंग
रेंडमाइजेस हैशेस। सो अटैकर्स कैन नॉट
रिलाई ऑन प्री कंप्यू्यूटेड टेबल्स। सिंपल
इसका आंसर इसलिए रेनबो टेबल अटैक क्यों
है? क्योंकि हैशिंग यहां पे सॉल्टिंग क्या
करती है? रेंडमाइजज़ हैशेस। हैशेस को
रैंडमाइज़ कर देती है। सो दैट अटैकर जो है
वो प्रीकंप्यूटेड टेबल पे अह डिपेंड हो के
ना रहे। एंड इसकी वजह से रेनबो टेबल अटैक
पॉसिबल नहीं हो पाती है। एज़ सिंपल एज़ दैट।
तो इसका आंसर ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक बिल्कुल
नहीं होगा। क्योंकि ब्रूट फ़ोर्स किसी भी
किसी भी तरह के पासवर्ड किसी भी तरह के अह
अह जो सिक्योरिटी मेजर्स है उस पे ट्राई
किया जा सकता है। फिशिंग तो कोई मतलब ही
नहीं रहता। फिशिंग आउट ऑफ कॉनंसेप्ट है
यहां पे। आउट ऑफ कॉन्टेक्स्ट है। डीडीओएस
आउट ऑफ कॉन्टेक्स्ट है। सॉल्टिंग का
फिशिंग और डीडीओएस से कोई लेना देना
बिल्कुल नहीं है। तो यहां पे आपका रेनबो
टेबल अटैक इज़ द आंसर। नेक्स्ट इज़ व्हिच
टूल इज़ यहां पे दो ऑप्शन नीचे आ गए हैं
थोड़े से। व्हिच टूल इज़ कॉमनली यूज़्ड फॉर
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग। क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग
के लिए कौन सा टूल यूज़ में लिया जाता है?
पहला वाशार्क ऑप्शन, बी ऑप्शन इज़
मेटास्प्लॉयड, सी ऑप्शन इज़ मेमिकार्ड्स,
डी ऑप्शन इज़ बबसूट। व्हिच इज़ द ऑप्शन?
प्लीज लेट मी नो। सिक्स्थ क्वेश्चन का कौन
सा ऐसा टूल है जो क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग के
लिए अभी मैंने रीसेंट में ही आपको यह
कराया था। मैंने रीसेंट में ही आपको ये
चीज़ बताई थी। इसका कौन सा टूल यूज़ होता
है? वायर शार्क मेटास्प्लॉयड। देखो वायर
शार का कोई मतलब यहां पे पहले ही नहीं हो
रहा है। मेटास्प्लॉयड का भी कोई मतलब नहीं
बनता है। बब सूट का भी कोई खास मतलब नहीं
बनता है। बचता है एक टूल हमारा मिमिकच। तो
ऑप्शन सी आपको आंसर्स को अ फ़्टर करने भी
आना चाहिए। जैसे मान लो आपको कोई कोई
क्वेश्चन का आंसर एग्जैक्टली नहीं पता है।
तो आपको जो चीजें लगती है ना कि जो आंसर
नहीं है उनको फ़िल्टर आउट कर दीजिए। जो बच
गया वो आंसर हो जाएगा। और अगर पहले से पता
है फिर तो आपका एकदम श्योर शॉट आंसर होना
चाहिए। तो यहां पे क्या है? mmcड mmcड
एक्सट्रैक्ट क्रेडेंशियल्स एंड हैशेस
फ्रॉम Windows मेमोरी मिमीज क्यों होगा?
क्योंकि मिमीड क्रेडेंशियल्स को क्या करती
है? एक्सट्रैक्ट करती है कहां से? Windows
के मेमोरी से। दैट्स व्हाई mcad इज़ यूज़्ड
फॉर क्रेडेंशियल्स डंपिंग। ये टूल यूज़ में
होता है। अब आते हैं
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] नेक्स्ट
क्वेश्चन पे। व्हिच Windows प्रोसेस
स्टोर्स ऑथेंटिकेशन क्रेडेंशियल्स? कौन सा
Windows प्रोसेस है जो ऑथेंटिकेशन के
क्रेडेंशियल्स को स्टोर करता है? अगेन दिस
इज़ अ समथिंग ट्रिकी क्वेश्चन। svc होस्टxe
एक्सप्लोरex
एलsxc विन logon exc ए बी सी और डी व्हिच
ऑप्शन इज देयर बताइए वि ऑप्शन यू वुड
सेलेक्ट
प्लीज लेट मी नो
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
काफी लोगों का आंसर है यहां पे सी। कुछ
लोगों का डी है आंसर। कुछ लोगों का डी है।
अ
एंड कुछ लोगों का सी है। अब यहां पे देखो
Windows प्रोसेस में ऑथेंटिकेशन स्टोर
करने का ऑथेंटिकेशन क्रेडेंशियल स्टोर
करने का sbc होस्ट से कोई लेना देना नहीं
है। पहली बात एक्सप्लोरर.exe से कोई लेना।
इन दोनों को तो वैसे ही निकाल दो दिमाग
से। अब बच गया एलs.exe विल logon.exee अब
ये दो जो चीजें हैं वो बच गई। अब मैंने आप
लोगों को एलsस के बारे में पढ़ाया था।
एलsस के बारे में आप लोगों को पढ़ाया था
मैंने बताया था। बताइए मुझे
एल्स अगर आपको याद होगा एल्स एस के बारे
में। राइट? तो यहां पे आ जाते हैं एल्स
हैंडल्स ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड स्टोर्स
क्रेडेंशियल मटेरियल। सिंपल सा फंडा है।
यहां पे एल्स.exc जो है विन logon.exc
क्रेडेंशियल्स को स्टोर करने के लिए यूज़
में नहीं लिया जाता है। wिन logon.exc इज़
द प्रोसेस जो Windows लॉगिन का प्रोसेस
सपोर्ट जो Windows लॉगिन आप करते हैं ना
वो प्रोसेस है। ऑथेंटिकेशन क्रेडेंशियल को
स्टोर करता है ls.exe
ls जो है वह स्टोर करता है ऑथेंटिकेशन
क्रेडेंशियल्स को। तो ये आपको दिमाग में
रखना पड़ेगा। कई बार क्वेश्चंस में
इंटरव्यूज क्वेश्चंस में आपको यहां पे
घुमा के पूछ दिया जाएगा। एंड वहां पे आप
कंफ्यूज हो जाएंगे। तो आपको ये नहीं देखना
है कि विन लॉग इन Windows लॉगिन टाइप नाम
है तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है कि क्रेडेंशियल
से रिलेटेड Windows लॉग इन क्रेडेंशियल से
रिलेटेड ये चीज़ होगी। नहीं। यहां पे ये
कंफ्यूज वाली है। यहां पे आपको एलsx आंसर
करना है जो कि Windows लॉग इन प्रोसेस का
ऑथेंटिकेशन क्रेडेंशियल्स को स्टोर करता
है। अब आते हैं नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन पे। ईजी
क्वेश्चन है। व्हिच अटैक रीडायरेक्ट्स
यूज़र्स टू अ फेक वेबसाइट विदाउट क्लिकिंग
अ मलेशियस लिंक? व्हिच अटैक रीडायरेक्ट्स
अ मलेशियस लिंक। बिना मलिशियस लिंक क्लिक
किए हुए रीडायरेक्ट करता है। ए में फिशिंग
है, दो में फार्मिंग है, तीन में स्मिंग
है, चार में बेटिंग है। अब बता दीजिए
मुझे।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
ए, बी, सी, डी व्हिच ऑप्शन इज़ करेक्ट?
ए फिशिंग, बी फार्मिंग, सी स्मिंग, डी
बेटिंग।
कई लोग यहां पर ए बोल रहे हैं। कई लोग बी
बोल रहे हैं।
कई लोग ए बोल रहे हैं। कई लोग बी बोल रहे
हैं। बताइए, बताइए, बताइए। सभी लोग आंसर
कीजिए। इसका थोड़ा ट्रिकी है। इसका थोड़ा
ट्रिकी है। बताइए।
देखिए
[खांसने की आवाज़]
हां [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
और देखिए इसका आंसर ऑब्वियस सी बात है। बी
बी होगी। इसका आंसर बी है। इसका मैं आपको
मैं आपको रीजन बता देता हूं। डीएनएस
पोइजनिंग का यहां पे यूज़ होता है। आपको
यहां पे आ जाते हैं। यहां पे अ बी पे
व्हिच अटैकर? आंसर इज़ बी। राइट? फार्मिंग।
इसका आंसर का उसका एक्सप्लेनेशन देख लेते
हैं। फार्मिंग मैनपुलेट्स डीएनएस टू
रीडायरेक्ट ट्रैफिक टू मलेशियस साइट्स।
मैंने इसके बारे में डिस्कस नहीं करा था
आपसे फार्मिंग के बारे में। डीएनएस वाली
डीएनएस पोइजनिंग वाली मैंने डिस्कस तो करी
थी आपसे जब मैंने क्लासेस ली थी तो आई
डिस्कस अबाउट डीएनएस पोइजनिंग कैसे डीएनएस
को मैनपुलेट करके रीडायरेक्ट कर दिया जाता
है आई हैड डिस्कस्ड दिस बट कई लोगों के
दिमाग में हो सकता है कि यह नहीं होगा
दिमाग में नई चीजें होंगी बट स्टिल यहां
पे आ रहा है कि फेक वेबसाइट पे रीडायरेक्ट
करता है बट बिना लिंक के क्लिक करे हुए अब
बिना लिंक के क्लिक करे हुए फिशिंग में
लिंक क्लिक होती है स्मिशिंग में लिंक
क्लिक होती है वेटिंग में लिंक क्लिक होगा
तो बच गया फार्मिंग। फार्मिंग में क्या
होता है? डीएनएस पोइजनिंग होती है। जहां
डीएनएस को डीएनएस के एंट्रीज को मॉडिफाई
करके वेबसाइट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
रीडायरेक्ट किया जाता है फेक वेबसाइट पे।
अब डीएनएस जो होती है उसके अंदर एंट्रीज
होती है अलग-अलग। उसमें ए रिकॉर्ड होता
है, एमएक्स रिकॉर्ड होता है। TXT रिकॉर्ड
होती है। देयर आर सी नेम रिकॉर्ड्स। देयर
आर मल्टीपल रिकॉर्ड्स। ए रिकॉर्ड में क्या
होता है? एक IP को उसके डोमेन पे पॉइंट
किया। मतलब एक डोमेन जो होता है उसको IP
पे पॉइंट किया जाता है जो भी सर्वर की
आईपी होती है तो उसी में वो फेक
रीडायरेक्ट वेबसाइट्स को किया जा सकता है
जिसको डीएनएस पोइजनिंग के थ्रू किया जाता
है जो कि यहां पे है कि मैनपुलेट डीएनएस
टू रीडायरेक्ट ट्रैफिक टू मलेशियस
वेबसाइट्स। सो इसका आंसर है फार्मिंग। बी
इज़ द आंसर। दैट्स इट। अब यहां पे आते हैं
नाइंथ क्वेश्चन पे। मूविंग बिटवीन कम
कॉम्प्रोमाइज सिस्टम्स इनसाइड अ नेटवर्क
इज़ कॉल्ड। ये बहुत ईजी क्वेश्चन है। आई
थिंक सबको आंसर पता होगा कि एक
कॉम्प्रोमाइज सिस्ट मूविंग बिटवीन
कॉम्प्रोमाइज सिस्टम एक नेटवर्क के अंदर
में कॉम्प्रोमाइज सिस्टम्स के अंदर मूव
करने को क्या कहते हैं? प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन, पर्सिस्टेंस, लेटरल मूवमेंट या
डेटा एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन। ऑप्शन ए, बी, सी,
डी। व्हिच ऑप्शन इज़ करेक्ट? इसका आंसर भाई
सबका सही होना चाहिए। नहीं तो बहुत पिटाई
होगी भाई। बहुत पिटाई होगी। अगर इसका एक
का भी आंसर गलत आया ना। देखो यह कौन है
यार? मिस्टर हुसैन ए आंसर कर रहे हैं
भैया। कहां से पढ़े हो भाई ये तुम शुभम
सोनी ये कहां से ए पढ़ के आए हो भाई शुभम
सोनी किससे पढ़ रहे हो तुम ये क्या यार
इतनी चीजें बता दी फिर भी ए यहां पे आंसर
है लेटरल मूवमेंट ये अभी जस्ट रिसेंट में
मैंने बताया था लास्ट क्लास ही लैटरल
मूवमेंट की हुई है और तुम इसका आंसर नहीं
करोगे ऐसे कैसे चलेगा कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड
सिस्टम्स के अंदर मूव करना एक नेटवर्क के
अंदर में लैटरल मूवमेंट कहलाता है
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन तो प्रिविलेज को
एस्केलेट करने के लिए पर्सिस्टेंस जो होती
बैकडोर एंट्री के लिए डाटा एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन
डाटा चुराने डाटा मतलब एक्सपोर्ट करने के
लिए तो लैटरल मूवमेंट होती है जो इनसाइड
नेटवर्क आप घूमते हैं। यहां पे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] भी आंसर में
देख लेते हैं। लैटरल मूवमेंट अटैकर्स
पाइवोट इंटरनली टू रीच हाई वैल्यू सिस्टम।
पाइवोटिंग इसको बोलते हैं। तो पाइवोट करके
लैटरल मूवमेंट के थ्रू ये एक मशीन से
दूसरे मशीन में कॉम्प्रोमाइज मशीन में
घूमते हैं अटैकर्स। इसको पाइवोटिंग कहा
जाता है। इस प्रोसेस को उसके अंदर लैटरल
मूवमेंट होती है। ठीक है?
ओके। अब यहां पे एक क्वेश्चन है। ये भी
इजी है। वि इंक्रिप्शन टाइप यूजसेस टू
कीज़। दो कीज़ का यूज़ होता है। कौन सा होता
है भैया? सिमेट्रिक, असिमेट्रिक, हैशिंग,
इनकोडिंग। बहुत ईजी है। बताया था मैंने।
बताइए सिमेट्रिक, असिमेट्रिक, हैशिंग,
इनकोडिंग। द आंसर कौन सा आंसर है? ए, बी,
सी, डी। बहुत ईजी क्वेश्चन है ये। यह भी
मैंने आपको डिस्कस करा हुआ था। तो, आई
थिंक इसका भी आंसर आप सबके सामने सही होना
चाहिए।
बताइए बताइए।
ओके। सो मोस्ट ऑफ यू हैव आंसर्ड द बी।
बिल्कुल सही आंसर है। असिमेट्रिक इज़ द
आंसर। क्यों? क्योंकि असिमेट्रिक में
प्राइवेट एंड पब्लिक की का यूज़ होता है।
पब्लिक एंड प्राइवेट कीज़ आर यूज़्ड। आंसर
एक्सप्लेनेशन भी सिमिलर है। राइट? तो हम
यहां पे बोलेंगे देखो ये क्वेश्चंस आपसे
इंटरव्यू में ऐसे पूछे जाएंगे। ओके? मुझे
बताइए कि अ द टाइप ऑफ इंक्रिप्शन दैट
यूसेस टू कीज़। तो आपको इंटरव्यू में ऐसे
पूछा जाएगा। द टाइप ऑफ इंक्रिप्शन दैट
यूजसेस टू कीज़। तो आपको वहां पे ये ऑप्शंस
नहीं दिए जाएंगे। आपको बताना है द
इंक्रिप्शन इज़ नोन ऐज़ असिमेट्रिक वेयर
पब्लिक एंड प्राइवेट कीज़ आर यूज्ड। बोथ आई
ये आपको ऐसे बताना है। आपको ये आंसर नहीं
करना है। असिमेट्रिक ऐसे नहीं बोलना है
इंटरव्यू में। अ क्वेश्चन पूछेगा सामने
वाले इंटरव्यूअर कि व्हिच टाइप ऑफ़
इंक्रिप्शन यूसेस द टू कीज़? तो आपको बोलना
है कि द असिमेट्रिक इंक्रिप्शन यूसेस द टू
कीज़। द पब्लिक एंड द प्राइवेट कीज़ आर
बीइंग यूज्ड इन द असिमेट्रिक इंक्रिप्शन।
दैट्स इट। इस तरीके से आपको आंसर करना है।
अब यहां पे आ रहे हैं नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन
पे।
फ्रॉडलेंट ईमेल्स टू स्टील क्रेडेंशियल्स
रिप्रेजेंट वि अटैक। फ्रॉडलेंट ईमेल्स टू
स्टील क्रेडेंशियल्स। रिप्रेजेंट वि अटैक?
फिशिंग मालवेयर डीडीओएस या एस्क्यूल
इंजेक्शन? ए, बी, सी और डी बताइए मुझे।
यह भी बहुत इजी है।
हां, बताइए।
बहुत अच्छी बात है। नहीं रुद्र ऑप्शन तो
देना ही है। ऑप्शन इसलिए देना है ताकि और
भी ऑप्शंस सभी लोगों को पता चले कि
एक्सैक्टली क्या-क्या ऑप्शंस यहां पे जो
दे रखे हैं उनमें चूज़ करना है हमें। एंड
यहां पर जितने भी लोग हैं मैं उनको
एब्सोल्यूट बिगिनर समझ के ये ट्रेनिंग करा
रहा हूं। तो उनके लिए ऑप्शंस अभी जरूरत
है। धीरे-धीरे आने वाले टाइम में जो
क्वेश्चंस हैं उनके लेवल भी थोड़े
बढ़ेंगे। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। एंड फिर आपको
कुछ और इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें भी देखने को
मिलेंगी। अलग तरीके से मिलेंगी। तो अभी तो
हम बेसिक से इसी तरीके से करेंगे। दिस इज़
द बेस्ट अप्रोच। अभी आने वाले अभी कुछ और
क्वेश्चंस भी आएंगे तो उसमें भी मैं आपको
बताऊंगा क्या अ उसका अप्रोच थोड़ा कुछ अलग
है। तो ओके हां हां यार भेज दूंगा पीडीएफ
भेज दूंगा टेंशन मत लो। सो फ्रॉड इमेज टू
स्टील कडनेंस रिप्रेजेंट कौन सा? फिशिंग।
ये बहुत नॉर्मल सा क्वेश्चन था। व्हिच
अटैक इनवॉल्व्स सेंडिंग फ्रॉड। तो फिशिंग
है। फिशिंग यूसेस डिसेप्टिव कम्युनिकेशन
टू ट्रिक द विक्टिम। सिंपल। ये बहुत ईजी
क्वेश्चन था। एंड इसका ईजी आंसर है। राइट?
मजा आ रहा है? मजा आ रहा है। चलिए अब एक
और क्वेश्चन है। यह भी बहुत ईजी है। व्हाट
डस आईओसी स्टैंड्स फॉर? अब मुझे बिना देखे
बताइए। आईओसी का फुल फॉर्म क्या होता है?
बिना देखे अपने आप बताइए। इसका आंसर इसका
तो मैं दे दूंगा आपको ऑप्शन। तो आप ऐसे ही
समझ जाओगे। आईओसी का फुल फॉर्म बताइए। ये
वन टू नहीं आप लोग लिखिए। लिखिए लिखिए।
आईओसी का फुल फॉर्म लिखिए। ऑप्शन मत भेजिए
यहां पे।
इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज।
इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज बिल्कुल सही
है। इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज। दिस इज़ द
ऑप्शन फुल फॉर्म एंड ऑप्शन इज़ ए। ए इज़ द
करेक्ट ऑप्शन। अब आपसे कोई ऑप्शन ऐसे दे
दे इंसिडेंट ऑफ़ क्राइम, इंटरनल ऑपरेशंस
कंट्रोल, इंटरनेट ऑपरेशन सेंटर तो ये सब
मत कर देना। इंडिकेटर ऑफ़ कॉम्प्रोमाइज़।
दिस इज़ द फुल फॉर्म ऑफ़ आईओसी। अब यहां पे
है व्हिच अटैक यूसेस लीक्ड क्रेडेंशियल्स
फ्रॉम प्रीवियस ब्रीच? प्रीवियस ब्रीच से
लीक्ड क्रेडेंशियल्स कौन सा अटैक यूज़ करता
है? ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक। ऑप्शन इज़
क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग, पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग,
डिक्शनरी। अब मुझे बताइए कौन सा यहां पे
ऑप्शन होगा? ए, बी, सी और डी। फर्स्ट
ऑप्शन ब्रूट फ़ोर्स, सेकंड क्रेडेंशियल
स्टफिंग, थर्ड पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग, डी एंड द
फोर्थ डी जो ऑप्शन है वो डिक्शनरी है। तो
इसका आंसर बताइए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। ओके। द आंसर इज़ क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग।
बिल्कुल सही है। यहां पे क्रेडेंशियल
स्टफिंग में क्या होता है? अटैकर्स
एक्सट्रैक्ट क्रेडेंशियल्स स्टर्ड इन
सिस्टम मेमोरी। तो एक्सट्रैक्ट करते हैं।
अटैकर्स जो होते हैं सिस्टम के मेमोरी में
जो क्रेडेंशियल्स होते हैं उसको
एक्सट्रैक्ट करते हैं फॉर दिस काइंड ऑफ़
अटैक। दिस इज़ कॉल्ड क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग
अटैक। तो ये आपको क्लियर देखो इन एमसीक्यू
और इन क्वेश्चन से आपका जो कांसेप्ट्स जो
आपने अभी तक पढ़े हैं वो भी क्लियर आउट हो
रहे हैं। वो भी रिवाइज होते हैं। एंड
इंटरव्यू के लिए आपका माइंडसेट प्रिपेयर
होता है। अब आपसे कोई देखो ये जब कर लोगे
ना तुम ये जो मैं करा रहा हूं अभी और जब
कर लोगे मैं गारंटी दे रहा हूं जो लोग
फुल्ली इनवॉल्वड हो के यहां पे इसमें अभी
पार्टिसिपेट कर रहे हैं। पूरा फोकस यहां
पे रख रहे हैं। मैं गारंटी दे रहा हूं। आप
लोग इसके बाद कोई भी आपसे पूछेगा ना ये
क्वेश्चंस इससे रिलेटेड क्वेश्चंस तो आप
उसको बिना एमसीक्यू के बिना कुछ देखे आप
डायरेक्ट आंसर कर पाएंगे। मैं आपको इस बात
की गारंटी देता हूं। अगर ऐसी बात
झूठ है तो बताओ।
लग नहीं रहा आपको कि आपसे अब कोई पूछेगा
आपसे कोई क्रॉस भी पूछ ले कि क्रेडेंशियल
स्टफिंग क्या होता है? तो यू कैन टेल द
अटैक व्हिच यूज यूजसेस द लीक्ड
क्रेडेंशियल्स फ्रॉम प्रीवियस ब्रचेस
क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग अटैक राइट
राइट
हां रुद्र क्वेश्चंस के अह डिफिकल्टीज़ एंड
प्रोसेससेस सब बढ़ेंगे। ये मैं इसको अपने
अकॉर्डिंग ही करा रहा हूं और बेसिक से
पहला स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं और धीरे-धीरे आगे
बढ़ेंगे। सो इट विल गो ऑन लाइक राइट दिस।
ओके चलिए ये बहुत अच्छी बात है। यहां पे
आपका आंसर बी था क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग।
दूसरा जो क्वेश्चन है व्हिच अटैक फ्लड्स
सर्वर्स विद ट्रैफिक? ट्रैफिक से फ्लड कर
देता है। ए मालवेयर, बी फिशिंग, सी
डीडीओएस, डी ब्रूड फ़ोर्स। आंसर बताइए।
इसका भी आंसर आई थिंक आप आराम से कर
पाएंगे।
बताइए आंसर बताइए। ऑलमोस्ट सभी का आंसर
सही होगा इसका।
ऑलमोस्ट [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सबका
आंसर सही है।
बहुत सिंपल था कि सर्वर्स के सर्वर्स को अ
फ्लड करता है ट्रैफिक से। वो आपका मैवेयर
तो है नहीं बिल्कुल भी। फिशिंग भी नहीं
होती है। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स भी नहीं होता है। बट
डीडीओएस इज़ देयर। डीडीओएस फ्लड्स द
सर्वर्स विद द ट्रैफिक्स। राइट? सो दिस इज़
द आंसर सी। डीडीओएस अब आइए
मजा आ रहा है अच्छी बात है मजा आ रहा है
तो अच्छी बात है मजा आना चाहिए सभी को अभी
और इंटरेस्टिंग कुछ क्वेश्चंस आने वाले
हैं अभी अभी प्रैक्टिकल बेस्ड क्वेश्चंस
कुछ आएंगे तब और ज्यादा मजा आएगा आपको
चलिए व्हिच टेक्निक्स एक्सट्रैक्ट्स
क्रेडेंशियल्स फ्रॉम सिस्टम मेमोरी ये
आई थिंक आपको पहले भी अभी रिसेंटली आपने
डील किया उसी का एक्सप्लेनेशन देखा था
आपने में यहां पे एक एमसीक्यू बेस्ड है।
व्हिच टेक्निक एक्सट्रैक्ट क्रेडेंशियल्स
फ्रॉम सिस्टम मेमोरी? बताइए। ए, बी, सी,
डी। बता दीजिए। ये तो बहुत आसान है। बताइए
बहुत आसान है ये।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बिल्कुल [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सही।
द आंसर इज़ क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग। अभी हमने
रिसेंटली देखा था। इट इज़ द टेक्निक दैट
एक्सट्रैक्ट्स क्रेडेंशियल्स फ्रॉम सिस्टम
मेमोरी। अब आइए। टारगेटेड फिशिंग एम्ड एट
अ स्पेसिफिक इंडिविजुअल इज़ कॉल्ड क्या? ए
बी सी डी। फिशिंग, स्पेयर फिशिंग, स्मिंग
एंड विशिंग। आंसर क्या है? यह भी आंसर
बहुत ईजी है। बताइए मुझे फटाफट। 16 का
आंसर बताइए आप लोग।
मेनी पीपल आर कुछ एक ने बोला प्रिया
प्रिया पाल ने बोला है बी। ए फिशिंग।
प्रिया पाल ने क्या बोला है? बी। ओके।
स्पेयर फिशिंग। ठीक है। कुछ लोग सी बोल
रहे हैं। टेक गाई इज़ सेइंग स्मिसिंग सी।
बिल्कुल गलत है। सी तो बिल्कुल नहीं होगा।
टेक गाई कैसे सी कैसे बोल रहे हो यार टेक
गाई सी का स्मिंग का मतलब है एसएमएस के
थ्रू फिशिंग करना यहां बात हो रही है
टारगेटेड फिशिंग जो किसी इंडिविजुअल पे हो
उसको हम स्पीयर फिशिंग बोलते हैं। एक
इंडिविजुअल एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अगेंस्ट
टारगेट करके जो फिशिंग की जाती है उसको हम
स्पीयर फिशिंग कहते हैं। यह देखिए
स्पियर फिशिंग अटैकस टेलर मैसेजेस यूजिंग
रिकनसेंस। रिकॉन करके उसके अगेंस्ट जो है
मैसेजेस उनके अगेंस्ट जो है फिशिंग करते
हैं। उसको हम स्पेयर फिशिंग बोलते हैं।
ठीक है? गॉट इट? चलिए। व्हाट डज़ एसआईएम
प्राइमरली डू? एसआईएम जो टूल है जो
प्लेटफार्म जो टेक्नोलॉजी है वो क्या करता
है? डेवलप मालवेयर लॉक कलेक्शन एनालिसिस
रिप्लेस एंटीवायरसेस डिसेबल अटैक्स ए बी
सी डी। एसआईएम का मेन काम क्या होता है?
एसआईएम टेक्न टेक्नोलॉजी जो है आपकी टूल्स
जो हैं आपकी टूल एसआईएम टूल्स उनका मेन
काम क्या होता है? ऑब्वियस सी बात है ये
एसओसी से रिलेटेड टूल है तो मैलवेयर डेवलप
तो करेगा नहीं। एंटीवायरस को कैसे रिप्लेस
करेगा? एंटीवायरस थोड़ी ना है यार। अटैक्स
को डिसेबल थोड़ी ना कर देगा। तो ऑब्वियस
सी बात है। लॉग कलेक्शन एंड एनालिसिस के
लिए एसआईएम टूल्स का यूज़ लिया जाता है।
सो आंसर इज़ बी। बिल्कुल। बी आंसर है। जिन
लोगों ने भी बी बोला है बिल्कुल सही बोला
है। आप परफेक्ट आपका आंसर है। कई लोग आंसर
बहुत सही-सही कर रहे हैं। अच्छी बात है।
अच्छा लग रहा है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] व्हिच
सिक्योरिटी प्रिंसिपल इंश्योरर्स डेटा इज
अनचेंज्ड? ये बताइए। बहुत सिंपल आंसर
इसका। कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी ए, बी इंटीग्रिटी,
सी अवेलेबिलिटी, डी ऑथेंटिकेशन। व्हिच
सिक्योरिटी प्रिंसिपल इंश्योर डेटा इज़
अनचेंज्ड। लेट मी नो। जल्दी बताइए सभी
लोग।
मोस्टली सेइंग पीपल आर इंटीग्रिटी? चलिए
आप जब इंटीग्रिटी बोल रहे हैं तो आंसर भी
इंटीग्रिटी है। बिल्कुल। इंटीग्रिटी
इंश्योरर्स दैट नो डेटा इज चेंज्ड
ड्यूरिंग द ट्रांसमिशन ऑफ़ डेटा। अगर कोई
आपसे पूछे इंटीग्रिटी का मतलब क्या है?
सिंपल सा फंडा है कि जो इंटीग्रिटी का
मतलब होता है कि नो डेटा इज़ बीइंग चेंज्ड।
नो डेटा इज़ बीइंग मॉडिफाइड ड्यूरिंग द
ट्रांसमिशन।
ठीक है? ठीक है? या ड्यूरिंग द
ट्रांसपोर्टेशन फ्रॉम वन सेंडर टू अनदर
वन। वन सेंडर टू रिसीवर या जो भी है। ठीक
है? बस
समझ में आ गया?
बिल्कुल करेंगे। बिल्कुल करेंगे यार।
इंटरव्यू सब क्रैक करेंगे। टेंशन नहीं
लेना है बस। चलिए अच्छी बात। अब आते हैं
क्वेश्चन पे। व्हिच प्रोटोकॉल इज़ यूज्ड
फॉर रिमोट Windows एक्सेस? व्हिच
प्रोटोकॉल इज़ यूज्ड फॉर रिमोट Windows
एक्सेस? ये भी बताइए। आसान है। ए में
एफटीपी, बी, आरडीपी, सी, एसएमटीपी, डी,
डीएनएस। बताइए मुझे ए बी सी डी सभी लोग
बताइए ए बी सी डी कौनसे बी आर डीपी बी बी
बी ओके बी ओके बी ओके ओके सब लोग बी यार
क्या यार तुम लोग
तुम लोग
तुम लोग सब जानते हो गजब
चलो लग रहा है अच्छी ट्रेनिंग जा रही है
आप लोगों की चलिए अच्छी बात है इसका आंसर
होगा बी आरडीपी रिमोट डेस्कटॉप प्रोटोकॉल
तो रिमोट विंडोज विंड विंडोज़ या मशीनंस को
रिमोटली एक्सेस करने के लिए आरडीपी
प्रोटोकॉल का यूज किया जाता है। ठीक है?
बहुत अच्छी बात है। अब यहां पे आते हैं
क्वेश्चन नंबर 20 पे। व्हिच ऑथेंटिकेशन
यूसेस मल्टीपल वेरिफिकेशन फैक्टर्स? कौन
सा ऑथेंटिकेशन है जो मल्टीपल वेरिफिकेशन
फैक्टर्स को यूज़ करता है? द आंसर ऑप्शंस
आर सिंगल फैक्टर एमएफए, पासवर्ड ओनली,
टोकनाइजेशन ए, बी, सी, डी बताइए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ए, बी, सी,
डी बताइए।
कौन सा ऐसा ऑथेंटिकेशन है जो मल्टीपल
वेरिफिकेशंस का को मल्टीपल वेरिफिकेशन
फैक्टर को फॉलो करता है तो सिंगल फैक्टर
ऑब्वियसली नहीं होंगे पासवर्ड ओनली
बिल्कुल नहीं होगा क्योंकि ये भी सिंगल है
टोकनाइजेशन से टोकनाइजेशन होती है यार
इसका कोई मतलब ही नहीं है उससे मल्टीपल
वेरिफिकेशन से तो हमारा होता है एक एमएफए
मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन सो आंसर इज़ बी
बिल्कुल सही जिन्होंने भी बी बोला है।
नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ व्हाट इज़ अलर्ट
ट्रायग? अलर्ट ट्रायग क्या है? व्हाट इज
अलर्ट ट्रैक? ऑप्शन ए इग्नोरिंग अलर्ट्स,
ऑप्शन बी इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग एंड प्रायिंग
प्रायोरिटाइजिंग अलर्ट्स, सी डिलीटिंग
लॉक्स, डी डिसेबलिंग एसआईएम। व्हाट इज द
आंसर?
बताइए सभी लोग बताइए।
ओके। बी बी कई लोग बी बोल रहे हैं। सच में
बी है।
क्या बात है यार।
क्या बात है बी [हंसी]
क्या बात है बी आंसर इज बी वेरी गुड वेरी
गुड बहुत अच्छी बात है बहुत अच्छी चलिए
आंसर इज़ बी क्योंकि अलर्ट ट्रैक का काम
होता है इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग एंड
प्रायोरिटाइजिंग द अलर्ट्स
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बस चलिए अब आते हैं आंसर प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन फ्रॉम यूजर टू एडमिन इज कॉल्ड
हॉरिजॉन्टल प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन वर्टिकल
प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन ेशन पैसिव प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन इंटरनल प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
इसका आंसर बताइए
इसका आंसर बताइए प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
फ्रॉम यूजर टू एडमिन यूजर से एडमिन के तरफ
हम कौन सा प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन करते हैं ए
बी सी और डी हॉरिजॉन्टल वर्टिकल
पैसिव और इंटरनल तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है
ऑब्वियस सी बात है जब हम यूजर से एडमिन की
तरफ जा रहे हैं राइट
तो कौन सा करते हैं हम वर्टिकल ऐसे ऐसे
वाले ऐसे वर्टिकल वाले को एक यूजर से
एडमिन की तरफ जा रहे हैं। तो वी आर गोइंग
फॉर द वर्टिकल। सो आंसर बी इज़ एब्सोलुटली
करेक्ट। द वर्टिकल वन। क्योंकि हॉरिजॉन्टल
में हम टीम को एस्केलेट करते हैं। टीम
जैसे एक नॉर्मल एंप्लई है। मैनेजरिकल या
मैनेजर के लेवल का उसको एक्सेस मिल जाएगा।
दैट इज़ हॉरिजॉन्टल। वर्टिकल में एक नॉर्मल
यूजर एक एडमिन यूजर के पास चला जाएगा।
राइट? दैट्स इट। दिस इज़ द थिंग। द बी आंसर
इज़ वर्टिकल।
[हांफने की आवाज़][गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
नाउ
यहां पे अब यहां पे क्वेश्चन है इवेंट
आईडी 4 सी 4625 रिप्रेजेंट्स सक्सेसफुल
लॉग इन फेल लॉग इन अकाउंट डिलीशन पासवर्ड
रिसेट इसका आंसर बताइए
इसका आंसर बताइए
देखिए इवेंट आईडी 4625
आ जाते हैं यहां पे
इवेंट आईडी 4625 आंसर बताइए। फेल लॉग इन
फेल लॉग इन नो आईडिया किसी को। अच्छा हां
अगर आप में से किसी को आईडिया नहीं है तो
आप लोग बता सकते हैं ना। आप लोग बोल सकते
हैं कि आईडिया नहीं है। सिंपल आप लोग बता
सकते हैं ना कि आईडिया नहीं है। तो आप लोग
सब लोग आंसर कर रहे हैं बिल्कुल। एकदम
धड़ल्ले से। सो इवेंट आईडी 4625 इज यूज्ड
फॉर फेल्ड लॉग इन। सिंपल आंसर इज़ फेल्ड
लॉगिन। द आंसर इज़ बी जो कि आपका फेल्ड
लॉगिन है। यही आपका आंसर है। ठीक है? तो
फेल्ड लॉग इन के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता
है। अब आते हैं यहां पे देखो, फेक
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] वाई-फाई
नेटवर्क अटैक इज कॉल्ड फेक वाई-फाई
नेटवर्क अटैक इज कॉल्ड क्या बोला जाता है
फेक Wi-Fi नेटवर्क अटैक को? अभी कई लोग
कंप्लेंट कर रहे थे कि सर सिर्फ बी आंसर
है। सर सारा आंसर बी है क्या? इसका भी बी
बोल दो भाई फार्मिंग। तुम लोग इसका भी
बोलो बी नहीं इसका बी आंसर होगा क्योंकि
मैं सारे के आंसर बी सेट करके आया हूं।
कुछ लोग बोल रहे थे सर सबका आंसर बी है
क्या? सबका बी आ रहा है। ऐसा नहीं है यार।
हां मल्टीपल आंसर्स हो सकते हैं बी बट
सबके नहीं है। ठीक है? सो फेक वाई-फाई
नेटवर्क अटैक को हम बोलते हैं क्या?
फार्मिंग बिल्कुल नहीं बोलते क्योंकि
फार्मिंग का आपने पहले देख लिया था। वह
दैट इज नॉट दिस कांसेप्ट स्मिसिंग बिल्कुल
नहीं बोलते टेल गेटिंग नहीं बोलते इविल
ट्विन अटैक इविल ट्विन
इविल [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ट्विन
अटैक
ठीक है दिस इज़ कॉल्ड एविल ट्विन जहां पे
फेक वाईफाई नेटवर्क क्रिएट करके एंड अटैक
किया जाता है फिशिंग का वाईफाई फिशिंग दिस
इज द आंसर नाउ नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ वि
एसओसी प्रोसेस
एनालाइज अलर्ट्स टू डिटरमाइन थ्रेट्स
अब इसका आंसर बताइए। ए, बी, सी, डी अलर्ट
ट्रैक, इंक्रिप्शन, बैकअप, पैच मैनेजमेंट।
बताइए इसका आंसर। व्हिच एसओसी प्रोसेस
एनालाइजज़ अलर्ट्स टू डिटरमाइन थ्रेट्स?
व्हाट इज द आंसर?
बताइए। सभी लोग आंसर कीजिए। ट्रिकी है ना?
कौन सा प्रोसेस है जो अलर्ट्स को एनालाइज
करके थ्रेट्स को डिटरमाइन करता है?
बिल्कुल सही। द आंसर जिन्होंने भी ए आंसर
करा है उनका बिल्कुल सही है। बाकी आंसर
जिन्होंने भी करा है उनका गलत है। अलर्ट
ट्रायग ही तो ऑप्शन है। ट्रायक तो तभी
करते हैं ना भाई। ट्राई तो तभी करते हैं
जब आप एनालाइज कर लेते हैं। अलर्ट्स को
एनालाइज करते हैं। थ्रेट्स को डिटरमाइन
करते हैं कि एग्जैक्टली ये किस चीज़ एक
ट्रू पॉजिटिव है, फॉल्स पॉजिटिव क्या है
ये? तो अलर्ट ट्रैग इज द आंसर जो कि ए
आंसर होगा 25 का अलर्ट ट्रैग। जिन्होंने
भी ए बोला बिल्कुल सही। जिन्होंने बाकी
बोले गलत। ठीक है? चलिए अब आते हैं यहां
पे। ये तो आपका हो गया एमसीक्यू क्वेश्चन।
दिस वाज़ द एमसीक्यू क्वेश्चन। नाउ वी आर
कमिंग ऑन शॉर्ट आंसर क्वेश्चन। शॉर्ट आंसर
क्वेश्चन। अब देखो ये जो शॉर्ट आंसर
क्वेश्चंस यहां पे मैंने आपके लिए यहां पे
बनाए हुए हैं। कुछ सी में यहां पे कुछ
सिनेरियो बेस्ड क्वेश्चन है। यहां पे डी
में यहां पे एनालिस थिंकिंग का क्वेश्चन
है। इसमें मैंने यहां पे आपको
मैं सॉरी सॉरी ऊपर ले जाओ। कहां गया भाई
ऊपर?
हां। अब मैंने यहां पे जो कहां गया? हां।
शॉर्ट आंसर क्वेश्चंस यहां पे दिए हैं।
ठीक है?
शॉर्ट आंसर क्वेश्चंस एक्सप्लेन द डिफरेंस
बिटवीन यह सब आंसर बी में है। बी के हैं
एंड देन सी में सिनेरियो बेस्ड क्वेश्चंस
है। मैं एक बार यहां पे अ
ये निकाल लेता हूं। एंड यहां पे आ जाते
हैं। ठीक है? इसको थोड़ा सा ज़ूम कर लेते
हैं। एंड यहां पे ये कर लेते हैं। चलिए अब
मैं इसके क्वेश्चंस डील करूंगा आपसे। एंड
देन इसके आंसर्स भी आपके साथ मैं डील
करूंगा। सो दैट यू गेट टू नो व्हाट शुड बी
द आंसर इज़। व्हाट शुड द आंसर इज़। एंड इसके
बाद हम सिनेरियो बेस्ड पे आएंगे और कुछ
प्रैक्टिकल क्वेश्चंस पे भी आएंगे। याद
रखिएगा वी आर गोइंग टू कम ऑन द ऑन ऑन सम
प्रैक्टिकल क्वेश्चंस आल्सो जो कि काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग होंगे। तो आप लोग रहिएगा तो
आपको वो चीज देखने को मिलेगा। अदरवाइज फिर
अगर नहीं रहेंगे तो फिर मुझे नहीं पता है।
बट अगर आप यहां रहते हैं जो भी उनको मजा
आने वाला है। बस मुझे इतना ही पता है। ठीक
है? ओके।
हम
ओके ठीक है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
अब यहां पे क्वेश्चन है एक्सप्लेन द
डिफरेंस बिटवीन हैशिंग एंड इंक्रिप्शन।
मैंने इसका ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ था। ये
क्वेश्चन आपके इंटरव्यू में हो सकता है कि
डिफरेंस बताइए हैशिंग और इंक्रिप्शन के
बीच में। सिंपल सा यहां पे मैं यहां पे
आंसर आपको दिखाता हूं। ये आंसर मैं आपको
एक ये आंसर मैं आपको यहां पे अभी डील कर
रहा हूं। देखो आप आंसर में थोड़ी बहुत
चेंजेस ला सकते हैं। ऐसा नहीं है कि मैं
जो यहां पे आंसर बता रहा हूं सेम आंसर
आपको करना है इंटरव्यू में। नहीं आप अपने
आंसर्स में ट्विस्ट ला सकते हैं। आपको
लगता है कि इससे परफेक्ट वे में भी थोड़ा
कुछ आपका आंसर है तो वो भी आप कर सकते
हैं। यूज़ हैशिंग इज़ वन वे एंड मेनली
यूज्ड फॉर पासवर्ड स्टोरेज एंड इंटीग्रिटी
वेरिफिकेशन। इंक्रिप्शन इज़ रिवर्सिबल
यूजिंग कीज़ एंड इज़ यूज़्ड टू प्रोटेक्ट
कॉन्फिडेंशियल डेटा। अब यहां पे यह जो
आंसर है, इसका मैं आपको मतलब समझाता हूं
कि क्यों ये आंसर बहुत अच्छा है। क्यों ये
आंसर परफेक्ट है? आपका आंसर भी बिल्कुल
सही हो सकता है। आप ऐसा बिल्कुल ना भी
बोले तो भी चलेगा। इंटरव्यूअर ऐसा नहीं है
कि इंटरव्यूअर उससे आपको गुस्सा हो जाएगा।
बट ये आंसर क्यों परफेक्ट है? मैं आपको
बताता हूं। आंसर इज़ हैसिंग इज़ वन वे एंड
मेनली यूज़्ड फॉर पासवर्ड स्टोरेज एंड
इंटीग्रिटी
वेरिफिकेशन।
देखो यहां पे तीन-तीन चीजें आ गई। तीनों
चीज़ें इस आंसर में आ गई। क्या कि हैशिंग
एक वन वे फंक्शन है। ये भी आ गया। हैशिंग
पासवर्ड स्टोरेज के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता
है। और हैशिंग इंटीग्रिटी को वेरीफाई करता
है। तो थ्री थिंग्स हैव बीन पुट इंटू दिस
आंसर। एंड दिस मेक्स दिस आंसर मोर परफेक्ट
देन अदर आंसर्स। तो आप जब आंसर्स में
टेक्निकिटी एंड टेक्निकल वर्ड्स को
इंक्लूड करते हो इंटरव्यूअर को और भी
ज्यादा अच्छा लगता है। इंटरव्यूअर गेट अ
इंप्रेस्ड। ये चीज होती है। नॉर्मली भी आप
बोल सकते हो कि अरे हैशिंग इज़ द वन वे
फंक्शन व्हिच स्टोर व्हिच इज़ यूज्ड टू
यूज़्ड फॉर पासवर्ड स्टोरेज और ऐसे
सिक्योरली कुछ भी ऐसे कर सकते हो। बट यहां
पे आप
थ्यरी में जितना कांसेप्ट आपको पता रहेगा,
जितना अच्छे से आप उतना अच्छे से इसका
आंसर दे सकते हैं। इंक्रिप्शन में क्या है
यहां पे? देखिए, इंक्रिप्शन इज़ रिवर्सिबल
यूजिंग
कीज़ एंड इज़ यूज़्ड टू प्रोटेक्ट
कॉन्फिडेंशियल डेटा। अब इसमें भी तीनों
पॉइंट्स आ गई। क्या आ गई भैया? कि
इंक्रिप्शन एक रिवर्सिबल प्रोसेस है जिसको
रिवर्स कर सकते हैं। जिसमें कीज़ का यूज़
होता है। जैसे अब सिमेट्रिक हो या
असिमेट्रिक हो। सिमिट्रिक होगी तो सेम की।
एक ही की ऑसिमिट्रिक होगी तो दो की पब्लिक
प्राइवेट की एंड इज़ यूज्ड टू प्रोटेक्ट
कॉन्फिडेंशियल डेटा। एंड यहां पे ये भी आ
गया कि कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को प्रोटेक्ट
करने के लिए इंक्रिप्शन का यूज़ में लिया
जाता है। तो ये बहुत ही एक बैलेंस्ड आंसर
है। एक छोटा भी आंसर है। बैलेंस्ड है।
मल्टीपल टेक्निकल पॉइंट्स को इंक्लूड
करके। अब ऐसे आंसर जब आप इंटरव्यूज में
जाके देंगे तो इंटरव्यूअर आपसे ज्यादा
इंप्रेस होगा देन द अदर कैंडिडेट्स जो कि
वो सेम आंसर करेगा। बट सेम सेम वर्डिंग्स
उसके नहीं होंगे। मतलब ऑलमोस्ट सेम रहेगा
कि हां भैया इंक्रिप्शन का मतलब होता है
कि डेटा को इंक्रिप्ट करके प्लेन टेक्स्ट
को। इंक्रिप्शन को आप ऐसे भी बोल सकते हो
टू कन्वर्ट प्लेन टेक्स्ट इंटू साइफर
टेक्स्ट या ऐसे। बट उससे ज्यादा बेटर आंसर
ये है आपकी जो आपकी टेक्निकल माइंडसेट को
यहां पे दिखाता है। जो आपके टेक्निकल
नॉलेज को दिखाता है कि बंदे को
कॉन्फिडेंशियल डेटा कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी के
बारे में पता है। बंदे को कीज़ के बारे में
पता है। रिवर्स रिवर्सिबल इररिवर्सिबल वो
भी पता है। मेरा मतलब आप समझ पा रहे हो?
मैं आपको क्यों आपके लिए यह सेशन लेकर आना
चाह रहा था? क्यों लेकर आया हूं? एंड
क्यों मैं आपसे डिस्कस करूं? क्योंकि ये
चीजें तो आप ऐसे भी इंटरनेट पे देख सकते
हैं। इंटरनेट पे Google कर सकते हैं। चैट
जीबीटी कर सकते हैं। आपको मिल जाएगी। बट
इस तरीके से चैट जीबीटी और इंटरनेट आपको
नहीं समझाएगा कि इंटरव्यू में कैसे आपको
प्रिपेयर करना है। दैट्स व्हाई समथिंग शुड
बी अ ओनली अ लेफ्ट फॉर ह्यूमंस नॉट द
एआईस।
राइट? चलिए गॉट इट? समझ में आ गया? चलिए
अब नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन की तरफ आते हैं।
व्हाट इज़ पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग एंड व्हाई इट
इज़ इट इज़ डिफिकल्ट टू डिटेक्ट? पासवर्ड
स्प्रिंग क्या है? एंड क्यों ये डिफिकल्ट
है डिटेक्ट करने में?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो देखो
पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग का
मतलब आप सबको तो पहले ही मैंने बताया हुआ
है। बट यहां पे आंसर्स किस तरीके से करना
है मेन वो मैटर करता है। तो यहां पे अब
आंसर में अगर आप कुछ इस तरीके से लिखते
हैं। देखिए यहां पे
पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग इज यूज पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग
यूज वन कॉमन पासवर्ड। पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग
यूज वन कॉमन पासवर्ड अक्रॉस मेनी अकाउंट्स
बिकॉज़ इट ट्राइज़ ओनली वन पासवर्ड पर
अकाउंट लॉकआउट्स आर अवॉयडेड। अब यहां पे
भी मल्टीपल चीज़ आ गई। मल्टीपल चीज़ आपने
बताई कि पासवर्ड स्प्रेइंग वन यूसेस वन
कॉमन पासवर्ड्स अक्रॉस मेनी अकाउंट्स। एक
कॉमन पासवर्ड मेनी अकाउंट्स में यूज़ होता
है। बिकॉज़ इट ट्राइज़ ओनली वन पासवर्ड पर
अकाउंट। क्योंकि ये एक ही पासवर्ड
मतलब पर अकाउंट जो है ट्राई यूज़ करता
ट्राई करता है। एक एक पासवर्ड एक अकाउंट
पे फिर वही पासवर्ड दूसरे अकाउंट पे फिर
वही पासवर्ड तीसरे अकाउंट पे। ऐसे कर करके
मल्टीपल अकाउंट्स पे चेक करता है।
लॉकआउट्स आर अवॉयडेड। इस वजह से लॉकआउट्स
जो है यहां पे अवॉयड होते हैं। यहां पे
लॉकआउट्स होने के चांसेस कम हो जाते हैं।
तो यहां पे भी मल्टीपल कांसेप्ट्स मल्टीपल
टेक्निकल टेक्निकल थिंग्स को इंक्लूड किया
गया इसके आंसर में। दैट्स व्हाई ये आंसर
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग है। काफी अच्छा है। आपको
लगता है कि आपका आंसर कुछ और भी हो सकता
है जिसमें हम मल्टीपल टेक्निकल थिंग्स को
इंक्लूड कर सकें तो आप वो भी आंसर कर सकते
हो। जरूरी नहीं है एग्जैक्ट डी सेम यही
आंसर करना है। यू कैन आंसर दैट इट आल्सो।
राइट? तो मेरी आप भावनाओं को समझ रहे हैं
आप लोग? मुझे यह बताइए। आर यू गेटिंग माय
भावनाएं या ऐसे ही बस बह रहे हो उसमें?
भावनाएं समझ में आ रही है मेरी?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके।
मैं आपको अभी जो बता रहा हूं पूरे YouTube
पर आपको कहीं नहीं मिलेगा। लिटरली आई एम
सेइंग अ
पूरे YouTube पे नहीं मिलेगा क्योंकि पूरे
YouTube पे जितने भी लोग अगर कोई इस तरह
की चीजें इस तरह की तो नहीं करा कराते हैं
जहां तक मैंने देखा है बट जो भी अगर ट्राई
भी करते हैं वो सिर्फ और सिर्फ आई हैव सीन
इसलिए करते हैं कि कहीं कुछ व्यूज आएंगे
हमारे पास लोग व्यूज के लिए वो करने लगते
हैं स्टार्ट कर देते हैं कोई घुसता नहीं
है अंदर में क्योंकि व्यूज आ रहे हैं लोग
आ रहे हैं हो गया बस दैट्स इट। जो
डिफ्रॉनिक्स आपके लिए चीज लेकर आती है
कंटेंट वो व्यूज के लिए तो लाती ही लाती
है। व्यूज तो आने ही आने हैं और आएंगे
आएंगे। बट उसमें एक्चुअल कंटेंट होता है।
उसमें रियल कंटेंट होता है। एंड उस चीज पे
फोकस भी बहुत ज्यादा होता है कि आपको
जेन्युइन और स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में एक्चुअल
उस टाइप की ट्रेनिंग मिले जो पेड ट्रेनिंग
के इक्वल आप समझे। उसको छोटा या कम ना
समझे। दैट्स द मेन थिंग। यह आपके समझ में
आना चाहिए। तो अगर आप कंटिन्यूड हैं तो
ऑब्वियस सी बात है आई एम आल्सो देयर फॉर
यू एवरीडे। चलिए अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे
क्वेश्चन आते हैं। क्वेश्चन पे आते हैं।
व्हाट व्हाट इज़ लैटरल मूवमेंट एंड व्हाई
डू अटैकर्स परफॉर्म इट? अब इसको आंसर करने
का बहुत तरीका है। लैटरल मूवमेंट क्या
होता है? बट हम यहां पे किस तरीके से
करेंगे? लैटरल मूवमेंट अकर्स लैटरल
मूवमेंट अकर्स व्हेन अटैकर्स मूव अक्रॉस
इंटरनल सिस्टम्स आफ्टर इनिशियल
कॉम्प्रोमाइज टू रीच हाई वैल्यू एसेट्स।
देखो यहां पे कितना कितना इंटरेस्टिंग ये
आंसर है। आप देखिए। लैटरल मूवमेंट अकर्स
व्हेन अटैकर्स मूव अक्रॉस इंटरनल
सिस्टम्स। इंटरनल सिस्टम्स के अक्रॉस मूव
करता है अटैकर। आफ्टर इनिशियल
कॉम्प्रोमाइज टू रीच हाई वैल्यू एसेट्स।
इनिशियल कॉम्प्रोमाइज करने के बाद इंटरनल
सिस्टम्स के बीच जब अटैकर मूव कर रहा होता
है। किस लिए? हाई वैल्यू एसेट्स के पास
पहुंचने के लिए, ऐसे कंप्यूटर, ऐसे मशीनंस
के पास पहुंचने के लिए जो आपको जो उसको और
ज्यादा सेंसिटिव या काम की इंफॉर्मेशन दे
सके। क्योंकि इनिशियल जो कॉम्प्रोमाइज
होती है उसमें बहुत ज्यादा डाटा या बहुत
ज्यादा काम की चीजें हो सकती है ना मिले
अटैकर को तो वह आगे की तरफ बढ़ता है ताकि
उसको हाई वैल्यू एसेट मिले। राइट?
राइट थैंक यू ब्रदर राजीव राजदेव यादव
थैंक यू वेरी मच [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके विष्णु ग्रेट बहुत अच्छी बात है थैंक
यू थैंक यू शुभम शुभम सोनी धन्यवाद
बिल्कुल करेक्ट आंसर सेुलर
लॉक आउट्स का आंसर ऊपर दिया है सेुलर ने।
आप उसको आंसर देख लीजिए एक बार। लॉकउट्स।
लॉकउट्स का मतलब होता है कि मल्टीपल ट्राई
के बाद आपका अकाउंट जो है वो लॉक हो जाना।
दैट्स इट। तो ये लैटरल मूवमेंट होती है।
अब आते हैं एक्सप्लेन वर्टिकल वर्सेस
हॉरिजॉन्टल प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन। अब बहुत
ईजी है ये। बट इसको हम कैसे पुट डाउन
करेंगे? वर्टिकल हॉरिजॉन्टल प्रिविज्लेशन
में क्या? वर्टिकल एस्केलेशन इंक्रीसेस
प्रिविलेजेस। हॉरिजॉन्टल एस्केलेशन
असेस अनदर अकाउंट विद सिमिलर प्रिविलेजेस।
बस यह दोनों के बीच की डिफरेंस आपको समझनी
है। वर्टिकल एस्केलेशन क्या करता है?
प्रिविलेज को क्या करता है? इंक्रीस करता
है। जैसे यूजर से एडमिन की तरफ। बट
हॉरिजॉन्टल एस्केलेशन जो करता है वो
एक्सेस
अनदर अकाउंट विद सिमिलर प्रिविलेज। इसका
काम है कि दूसरे अकाउंट को एक्सेस करना
विद सिमिलर ऑलमोस्ट सिमिलर प्रिविलेज। ठीक
है? ऑलमोस्ट सिमिलर थोड़ी बहुत ऊपर नीचे
होगी ऑब्वियस सी बात है क्योंकि प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन बट मेन है कि सिमिलर अनदर
अकाउंट कोई और अकाउंट विद ऑलमोस्ट सिमिलर
प्रिविलेजेस ये हॉरिजॉन्टल एस्केलेशन होता
है। वर्टिकल में क्या होता है? सिंपल यू
जैसे एडमिन ऐसे नॉर्मल जो एस्केलेशंस होती
है। तो ये आपका डिफरेंस हो गया। अब आते
हैं यहां पे व्हाट इज़ क्रेडेंशियल
स्टफिंग? ये बहुत आसान है इसका आंसर। यह
आप नॉर्मली आंसर कर सकते हैं। क्रेडेंशियल
स्टाफिंग यूज़ प्रीवियसली लीक्ड यूजरनेम
पासवर्ड कॉम्बिनेशंस टू एक्सेस अदर
सर्विसेस। सी ये आपको ऑलरेडी पता थी कि
क्रेडेंशियल स्टाफिंग जो है वो प्रीवियस
लीक्ड यूजरनेम पासवर्ड्स का यूज़ करती है
टू एक्सेस अदर सर्विज। बहुत सिंपल सा ये
क्वेश्चन था। एंड
इसका आंसर आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। ठीक
है? अब आते हैं एक्सप्लेन द कॉनंसेप्ट ऑफ
सॉल्टिंग इन पासवर्ड स्टोरेज। सॉल्टिंग का
कांसेप्ट समझना है भैया। तो सॉल्टिंग एड्स
रैंडम डेटा बिफोर हैशिंग पासवर्ड्स टू
प्रिवेंट रेनबो टेबल अटैक्स। देखिए कितना
अच्छा और कितना सिंगल लाइन और कितना टू द
पॉइंट आंसर है। सॉल्टिंग क्या है भैया? तो
सॉल्टिंग एड्स रैंडम डेटा बिफोर हैशिंग।
हैशिंग से पहले रैंडम डेटा डाल देता है।
ठीक है? टू प्रिवेंट रेनबो टेबल अटैक।
इसमें यह भी कांसेप्ट आ गया कि किस लिए
करता है भैया यह? रेनबो टेबल अटैक से
प्रिवेंट करने के लिए। बहुत सिंपल। राइट?
बहुत सिंपल आंसर है। सॉल्टिंग इसलिए यूज़
तो होता है एड्स रैंडम डाटा बिफोर हैशिंग
पासवर्ड्स
टू प्रिवेंट रेनबूटेबल अटैक। ये सिंपल आप
आंसर कर सकते हैं। व्हाट आर इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
कॉम्प्रोमाइज? इसका एग्जांपल भैया। तो
इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज क्या होते
हैं? तो आईओसीस आर आर्टिफेक्ट्स
इंडिकेटिंग मलेशियस एक्टिविटी सच ऐ मशियस
एक्टिविटीज़ को बताने के लिए होते हैं।
इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ़ कॉम्प्रोमाइज़। इंडिकेटर्स
ऑफ़ कॉम्प्रोमाइज क्या होते हैं? कि एक
कॉम्प्रोमाइज होने का इंडिकेटर कि भैया
कहीं कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो गया है तो उसका
इंडिकेटर या कॉम्प्रोमाइज होना जो है किसी
प्रोसेस कॉम्प्रोमाइज के अंडरगॉन है कोई
चीज तो उसको इंडिकेट करना जैसे कि कैसे
मलेशियस आईपीस फाइल के हैशेस और सस्िशियस
डोमेनस इनको इंडिकेट करते हैं तो ये होते
हैं इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ कॉम्प्रोमाइज कोई चीज
कॉम्प्रोमाइज होने का इंडिकेशन ये होता है
सिंपल सा फंडा एक्सप्लेन द डिफरेंस बिटवीन
फिशिंग एंड स्पयर फिशिंग। ये भी आप आराम
से इसका आंसर कर सकते हैं। फिशिंग
टारगेट्स मेनी यूज़र्स। स्पेयर फिशिंग
टारगेट्स स्पेसिफिक इंडिविजुअल्स। सिंपल
आंसर फिशिंग जो है वो बहुत सारे यूज़र्स को
टारगेट करता है। बट स्पेयर फिशिंग
टारगेटेड इंडिविजुअल्स को टारगेट करता है
या सिलेक्टेड इंडिविजुअल्स को या
स्पेसिफिक इंडिविजुअल्स को टारगेट करता
है। दिस इज़ द मेन डिफरेंस बिटवीन फिशिंग
एंड स्पेयर फिशिंग। आई थिंक आप ये भी समझ
गए होंगे। अब चलिए
व्हाट इज़ इविल टू इन अटैक? ये भी बहुत
आसान है यहां पे। अटैकर्स क्रिएट फेक
वाई-फाई नेटवर्क मेमिकिंग अ लेजिटमेट वन
टू इंटरसेप्ट द ट्रैफिक। मतलब एबिल टन
अटैक में क्या होता है? अटैकर क्या करता
है? फेक वाई-फाई नेटवर्क क्रिएट करता है।
एंड एक रियल लेजिटमेट नेटवर्क को कॉपी
करता है। किस लिए? किस लिए करता है? यह
स्निफिंग करने के लिए। स्निफिंग या मैन इन
द मिडिल अटैक करने के लिए। ट्रैफिक को
इंटरसेप्ट करने के लिए ट्रैफिक को
इंटरसेप्ट करेगा तो वो स्निफिंग मैन इन द
मिडिल अटैक का प्रोसेस ल्च कर सकता है।
इसलिए इविल ट्विन अटैक जो है ये होती है
अटैकर्स क्रिएट अ फेक वाई-फाई नेटवर्क
मेकिंग अ लेजिटमेट वाई-फाई नेटवर्क टू
इंटरसेप्ट ट्रैफिक। ये इसका आंसर हो सकता
है। देन है व्हाट इज़ अलर्ट ट्रैक इन एसओसी
ऑपरेशन? एसओसी ऑपरेशन में अलर्ट ट्रैक
क्या होता है? इसका बहुत सिंपल आंसर आप कर
सकते हैं। अलर्ट ट्रायग इज़ द प्रोसेस ऑफ़
रिव्यूइंग एंड प्रायोरिटाइजिंग अलर्ट्स टू
डिटरमाइन वेदर दे रिप्रेजेंट रियल
इंसिडेंट्स। बस सिंपल सा फंडा है। अलर्ट
ट्राय का मतलब है ऑफ़ रिव्यूइंग इज़ अ
प्रोसेस ऑफ़ रिव्यूइंग एंड प्रायोरिटाइजिंग
अलर्ट्स। रिव्यू करना अलर्ट्स को और उसको
प्रायोरिटाइज़ करना टू डिटरमाइन वेदर दे
रिप्रेजेंट रियल इंसिडेंट्स। ठीक है? टू
रिप्रेजेंट
रियल इंसिडेंट्स। क्या है? वेदर दे
रिप्रेजेंट्स वेदर दे रिप्रेजेंट्स रियल
इंसिडेंस इस बात को देखने के लिए कि जो
चीजें हुई हैं वो एक्चुअल रियल इंसिडेंस
हुई है या नहीं हुई है ये बताने के लिए कि
ट्रू भी है कि फॉल्स है कि ट्रू पॉजिटिव
है फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है क्या है वो बताने के
लिए आपका अलर्ट ट्रायग होता है। ये सब
चीजें जो हैं आपको पता है। ये सब चीजें
आपको ऑलरेडी पता थी। बस इसको आंसर करना
आपको आना चाहिए। जब आप इंटरव्यूज में
जाएंगे तो आप प्रॉपर फुल सेंटेंस में आंसर
करते हैं। आप शॉर्ट आंसर्स कभी नहीं करते
हैं ना कभी करना चाहिए इंटरव्यूज के टाइम
में। जब आपसे कोई क्वेश्चन पूछे तो उसको
डिटेल में बताना है। अब देखो उसको एक
स्पेसिफिक डिटेल वे में बताना है। ऐसा भी
नहीं बताना कि आप बोलते जा रहे हैं, बोलते
जा रहे हैं। इंटरव्यूअर भी सोचेगा अरे यार
ये क्या बोल रहा है यार? इंटरव्यूअर का भी
दिमाग हिल जाए। एक लिमिटेड सेंटेंस बट
काफी इफेक्टिव सेंटेंस में आपको बोलना है।
टेक्निकल चीजों को उसमें ऐड करना है ताकि
आपका जो आंसर है वो बाकी कैंडिडेट से
ज्यादा परफेक्ट लगे इंटरव्यूअर को क्योंकि
आपसे जो क्वेश्चन पूछा जा रहा है व्हाट इज़
अलर्ट ट्राय वही क्वेश्चन 10 और
कैंडिडेट्स बैठे होंगे उनसे भी पूछा
जाएगा। अगर सबको पता है जिसको देखो 10 में
से मान लो दो को नहीं पता तो दो तो वैसे
ही छट जाएंगे हट जाएंगे। लेकिन आठ को अगर
पता है तो अब आठ उन आठों में से उनको
सेलेक्ट करना पड़ता है। तो वो देखेंगे कि
कौन किस तरह से आंसर कर रहा है। उस पे वो
उसको जज करते हैं। राइट? या लिमिटेड व्हाट
वैलिड? बिल्कुल सही। तो ये था आपका सेक्शन
टू जिसमें कि हमने शॉर्ट आंसर क्वेश्चंस
करे हैं। ठीक है? अब आते हैं सेक्शन थ्री
पे। ये आपका सिनेरियो बेस्ड क्वेश्चन है।
सिनेरियो बेस्ड क्वेश्चन है। सेक्शन थ्री
पे। अब इसको थोड़ा सा ध्यान से देखिएगा।
सिनेरियो वन है 500 फेल्ड लॉगिन
अटेम्प्ट्स फ्रॉम वन आईपी टारगेटिंग अ
सिंगल अकाउंट इसको हम क्या बोलेंगे बताइए
बताइए
500 फेल लॉगिन अटेम्प्ट्स फ्रॉम
वन आईपी
टारगेटिंग अ सिंगल अकाउंट बताइए इसका आंसर
क्या होगा
अह विदु शेखर हैज़ डन ₹40 ऑफ़ सुपर चैट ओके
थैंक्स अह विदु शेखर
हालांकि सुपर चैट की जरूरत नहीं होती है
बट स्टिल थैंक यू वेरी मच।
ओके ओके चलिए आ जाते हैं यहां पे आंसर पे।
लॉग शोज़ 500 फेल्ड लॉगिन अटेमप्ट्स फ्रॉम
द सेम आईपी टारगेटिंग वन अकाउंट। तो इसका
आंसर क्या है? सिंपल सा है। इसका आंसर
सिंपल सा है। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक। मेनी
पासवर्ड अटेम्प्ट्स अगेंस्ट वन अटैक। तो
इसका आंसर है ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक। जिन लोगों
ने भी ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक आंसर करा है
बिल्कुल सही करा है। एब्सोलुटली राइट। एंड
इसमें अब आपको मल्टीपल कुछ एमसीक्यू
क्वेश्चन वो नहीं मिलेंगे आपको आंसर्स के
अ जैसा उस समय रुद्र भी बोल रहा था ना तो
आपको यहां पे ऑप्शंस नहीं मिलेंगे। यहां
पे आपको आंसर करना है। तो अभी देखते हैं
कितने लोग क्या आंसर कर रहे हैं। बिल्कुल
जिन्होंने भी ब्रूट फ़ोर्स करा है वो
बिल्कुल सही करा है। सर व्हाट इज द
डिफरेंस बिटवीन ब्रूट फ़ोर्सोर्स एंड DOS?
अरे यार ये क्वेश्चन मत करो यार। ये ये
गड़बड़ क्वेश्चन है। ब्रूटफुथ और DS में कोई
डिफरेंस क्या है यार? बहुत बड़ा बहुत बड़ा
डिफरेंस है। दोनों अलग-अलग टाइप के अटैक्स
हैं। बताऊंगा मैं। वैसे बताया हुआ है बट
आप लोग क्या करें? रिकॉर्डिंग अच्छे से
फॉलो ही नहीं करते हो। वन पासवर्ड
अटेम्प्टेड अक्रॉस 200 अकाउंट्स। इसको
क्या बोलेंगे? बताइए। वन सेकंड का आंसर।
वन पासवर्ड अटेम्प्टेड
ओवर 200 अकाउंट्स। व्हाट विल बी द आंसर,
गाइज़? लेट मी नो। प्लीज लेट मी नो।
वन पासवर्ड अटेम्प्टेड अक्रॉस 200
अकाउंट्स? इसका आंसर लोग बोल रहे हैं
पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग रिवर्स ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक। पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग रिवर्स बूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक। ठीक है? अब आते हैं यहां पे आंसर
पे। इज़ द पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग अटैक? मैंने
पहले भी बताया हुआ था कि एक पासवर्ड जब
बहुत सारे अकाउंट्स पे ट्राई किया जाता है
उसको हम पासवर्ड स्प्रेइंग अटैक बोलते
हैं। ठीक है? सो जिन्होंने भी पासवर्ड
स्प्रिंग अटैक बोला है उनका आंसर बिल्कुल
सही है।
कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू एवरीबॉडी।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज मिमिक कार्ड
एग्जीक्यूट हुआ है।
mिका एग्जीक्यूट हुआ है। देन एल्स को
एक्सेस किया गया है। देन एडमिन लॉग इन हुआ
है। देन आरडीपी टू फाइल सर्वर हुआ है।
यहां पे क्या हो रहा है? एग्जैक्टली बताइए
मुझे। बताइए यहां पे क्या हो रहा है?
एग्जैक्टली
यहां पे क्या हो रहा है?
जल्दी बताइए जल्दी फटाफट
आंसर इट मेमिका एलसा एक्सेस एडमी लॉग इन
आरडीबी टू फाइल सर्वर
या बिल्कुल सही यहां पे आ जाते हैं यहां
पे जो मैंने पहले ही बताया था लास्ट क्लास
में वही चीजें यहां पे हो रही है आंसर
क्या है क्रेडेंशियल्स डंपिंग हो रहे हैं
देन प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन हो रहा है देन
लैटरल मूवमेंट हो रहा है यह मैंने मैंने
पहले ही बोला था। इसके पिछले क्लास में
मैंने बताया हुआ था। राइट? राइट? मैंने
इसके पहले वाली क्लास में ही बताया था ये
कि यहां पे तीन चीजें हो रही हैं।
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग भी हो रहा है। मिमी
कार्ड एग्जीक्यूटेड और एल्स एक्सेस हुआ तब
ये क्रेडेंशियल डंप हुआ। एडमिन लॉग इन
हुआ। प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन हुआ। और आरडीबी
टू फाइल सर्वर एक जगह से दूसरी जगह जब मूव
किया नेटवर्क के अंदर में तो ये लेटरल
मूवमेंट कहलाता है। सो ये आपको ध्यान में
रखना है। पहले बताया हुआ है मैंने बट आई
थिंक आपको याद नहीं है या तो याद रहता तो
आप इसका आंसर जरूर उसी तरीके से करते। तो
दिस इज़ क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग प्रिविलशन एंड
देन लैटरल मूवमेंट। राइट? नेक्स्ट
क्वेश्चन इज़ ईमेल आपको एक आती है। योर
अकाउंट विल बी सस्पेंडेड। क्लिक हियर टू
रिसेट पासवर्ड। यह किस टाइप का ईमेल है?
इट्स ईजी क्वेश्चन। इट्स अ ईजी क्वेश्चन।
सो यहां पे ईमेल जो आती है फिशिंग
अटेमप्ट। सिंपल। इस तरह का ईमेल आता है
जहां पे क्लिक हियर टू रिसेट पासवर्ड। ये
एक फिशिंग अटेम्प्ट है। उसके बाद लॉग इन
फ्रॉम इंडिया फॉललोड बाय रशिया विद इन 3
मिनट्स। इसको आप कैसे देखेंगे? क्या
देखेंगे आप? लॉग इन फ्रॉम इंडिया फॉललोड
बाय रशिया विद इन 3 मिनट्स। इसका बताइए।
लॉग इन फ्रॉम इंडिया फॉललोड बाय रशिया विद
इन 3 मिनट्स। बताइए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
व्हाट इज द आंसर?
इसका बताओ भाई। इसका बताओ सभी लोग। लॉग इन
फ्रॉम इंडिया फॉललोड बाय रशिया।
विद इन 3 मिनट्स।
लेटरल मूवमेंट कैसे होगा यार? क्या बोल
रहे हो?
मतलब अलर्ट में आया लॉग इन फ्रॉम इंडिया
फॉललोड बाय रशिया विद इन 3 मिनट्स।
नो आईडिया।
ओके। चलिए आ जाते हैं यहां पे। यहां पे
आंसर देखिए यहां पे। इंपॉसिबल ट्रेवल
इंडिकेटर सजेस्टिंग पॉसिबल अकाउंट
कॉम्प्रोमाइज। मतलब यहां पे क्या है कि ये
जो ट्रैवलिंग हो रही है एक लॉग इन 3 मिनट
में एक लॉग इन कहां हुआ है? इंडिया से हुआ
है। दूसरी लॉग इन कहां हुआ है? रशिया से
हुआ है। तो अब 3 मिनट में दुनिया की कोई
ऐसी ट्रांसपोर्टेशन नहीं है जो बंदा
इंडिया से रशिया पहुंच जाएगा। तो ये क्या
है? इंपॉसिबल ट्रेवल हिस्ट्री है।
इंपॉसिबल ट्रेवल लॉग इन हिस्ट्री है। तो
इंपॉसिबल ट्राइवल इंडिकेटर जो है आपका कि
ये ट्राइवल इंपॉसिबल है। दिस इज़ नॉट
पॉसिबल ट्रेवल। राइट? तो यह इंपॉसिबल
ट्राइवल है। इसका मतलब यह है कि आपका
अकाउंट कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुआ है। क्योंकि अगर
आपका अकाउंट कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुआ है तभी तो
इंडिया से एक लॉगिन हुआ तो हो सकता है उस
यूजर ने लॉगिन किया हो जिसका अकाउंट है।
और रशिया से एक लॉग इन हुआ तो हो सकता है
जिसने कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया अकाउंट को उसने
लॉगिन किया हो तीसरे मिनट पे या थर्ड मिनट
पे। तो 3 मिनट में दो लॉगिन यहां पे आपको
दिख रहे हैं। राइट? सो दिस इज़ नोन एज
इंपॉसिबल ट्रेवल इंडिकेटर। इसको आप
बोलेंगे सजेस्टिंग पॉसिबल अकाउंट टेक ओवर
या अकाउंट कॉम्प्रोमाइज। राइट?
गॉट इट? यह मैंने बताया हुआ है टेक गाई
ऑलरेडी बताया हुआ है। आप लोग क्लासेस सही
से देखोगे तो आपको समझ में आएगा। ऑलरेडी
इसकी डिस्कशन हुई है। इसलिए मैं नहीं बता
रहा। सो, प्लीज डोंट स्पैम।
ठीक है? लव फ्रॉम नेपाल। आई एम नॉट रेगुलर
व्यूअर ऑफ योर बिकॉज़ आई एम स्टिल वाचिंग
ओल्ड रिलेशंस। जस्ट अराइव्ड एट क्लास सेवन
बिकॉज़ आई स्टार्टेड दिस कोर्स लेट। ग्रेट।
बहुत अच्छी बात है। लव फ्रॉम इंडिया,
ब्रदर। गॉट इट? चलिए, अब यहां पे आते हैं
सेक्शन डी पे। यह है एनालिस्ट थिंकिंग। यह
एनालिस्ट थिंकिंग को रिप्रेजेंट करता है।
आपके एनालिस्ट वाली थिंकिंग यहां पे देखने
को मिलेगी। लेट्स सी कितनी थिंकिंग कैसी
है? व्हाट स्टेप्स वुड यू टेक
इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग अ सस्िशियस लॉग इन अलर्ट?
मुझे बताइए क्या-क्या स्टेप्स आप लेंगे?
चैट में बताइए।
बताइए चैट में।
व्हाट स्टेप्स वुड यू टेक इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग
अ सस्िशियस
लॉगिन अलर्ट?
आप अपने हिसाब से क्या स्टेप्स लेंगे?
बताइए। इन्वेस्टिगेट कर रहे हैं अगर
सस्िशियस लॉग इन अलर्ट को तो क्या स्टेप्स
लेंगे?
पहले सभी लोग बताइए। फिर मैं आता हूं इस
पे।
अब आंसर्स नहीं आ रहे लोगों के।
यूजर को आइसोलेट पासवर्ड चेंज पहले तो
आईपी
रेपो चेक करूंगा ठीक है चेक रिक्वेस्ट पर
मिनट Jio लोकेशन लेजिट यूजर ऑ नॉट ठीक है
फर्स्ट वेरीफाई अलर्ट चेक आईपी ठीक है
अलर्ट रिवुइंग ओके चेक वो लॉग इन कहां से
करी है ठीक है
प्रीवियस आईपी लोकेशन ओके
अलॉट डिटेक्ट अलर्ट ट्रैक डॉक्यूमेंटेशन
एस्केलेशन इफ नीडेड ओके बहुत अच्छी बात है
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
यूजर अकाउंट टेंपरेरी ब्लॉक रिसेट एंड ठीक
है चेक आईपी एड्रेस एंडेशन ठीक है काफी
लोगों ने काफी आंसर्स करे हैं यहां पे आ
जाते हैं यहां पे आंसर्स पे सबसे पहला
यहां पे कुछ लोगों ने बहुत अच्छा आंसर करा
है यहां पे तो कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू देम
डिटेल में आंसर करा है कुछ लोगों ने जब भी
कोई सस्पिशियस लॉग इन अलर्ट होगा तो सबसे
पहला काम है आपको IP एड्रेस को चेक करना
दूसरा Jio लोकेशन कहां से लॉग इन हुआ है
वह चेक करना
यूजर के बिहेवियर को चेक करना। वह लॉगिन
करके क्या मतलब किस तरह का बिहेवियर कर
रहा है। किस तरह की चीजें करने की कोशिश
कर रहा है। डिवाइस कौन सी है जिससे लॉग इन
हुई है? लॉग इन का टाइम क्या है? एंड
ऑथेंटिकेशन लॉग्स को चेक किया जाएगा कि
भैया ऑथेंटिकेशन लॉग्स में क्या आया हुआ
है? है वहां तो कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग कोई इनेशन
कुछ ऐसा तो नहीं है। तो यहां पे आंसर में
आपको डिटेल्ड में सब कुछ मेंशन करना है।
जब भी आपसे कोई पूछेगा डिटेल में व्हाट
स्टेप्स शुड यू टेक टू इन्वेस्टिगेट अ
सस्सेशियस लॉग इन अलर्ट। कोई भी सस्पिस
लॉग इन अलर्ट हो रहा है तो भ आप क्या
करेंगे? सिंपल मैं एड्रेस को चेक करूंगा।
Jio लोकेशन को चेक करूंगा। देखूंगा यूजर
के बिहेवियर क्या है? डिवाइस की इनफो क्या
है? लॉग इन का टाइम क्या है यहां पे? एंड
जो ऑथेंटिकेशन लॉग्स हैं उनको मैं चेक
करूंगा। सिंपल बिल्कुल सही। कुछ लोगों ने
यस यस कुछ लोगों ने बिल्कुल सही आंसर किया
था। मतलब काफी चीजें इंक्लूड करी हुई थी।
अ आपका आंसर बिल्कुल सही है।
या कुछ लोगों ने आंसर अच्छा किया था। बहुत
टू
नियर अबाउट किया हुआ था। तो दैट्स फाइन।
गुड।
वेरी गुड। चलिए, यह आंसर समझ में आ गया
आपको। अब आते हैं यहां पे दूसरे पे। इफ अ
यूजर क्लिक अ फिशिंग ईमेल, व्हाट शुड
एसओसी डू फर्स्ट? बताइए मुझे। इफ अ यूजर
क्लिक अ फिशिंग ईमेल, व्हाट शुड यूजर
व्हाट शुड एसओसी डू फर्स्ट? अगर किसी यूजर
ने फिशिंग ईमेल पे क्लिक कर दिया है, तो
एसओसी को सबसे पहले क्या करना चाहिए?
आइसोलेट फर्स्ट। ठीक है? और लोग बताइए।
बाकी लोग बताइए।
एंड पॉइंट आइसोलेशन। ठीक है?
आइसोलेट द मशीन फर्स्ट।
चेंज पासवर्ड। आइसोलेट द सिस्टम, स्कैन द
यूजर सिस्टम। आईपी ब्लॉक, आइसोलेट द। ठीक
है? चलिए, कुछ लोग आइसोलेट बोल रहे हैं।
कुछ लोग आईपी ब्लॉक बोल रहे हैं। कुछ
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
लोग पासवर्ड चेंज करने को बोल रहे हैं।
एंड पॉइंट आइसोलेट एंड फिशिंग लिंक ये सब
आ रहा है। अब यहां पर आते हैं। इफ अ यूजर
क्लिक अ फिशिंग ईमेल व्हाट शुड द एसोसिस
एनालिस्ट डू? तो यहां पर सबसे पहले रिसेट
क्रेडेंशियल्स।
आइसोलेट द सिस्टम इफ नेसेसरी स्कैन द एंड
पॉइंट एंड रिव्यू द लॉक्स। बिल्कुल सही।
तो आपको क्रेडेंशियल्स को तो रिसेट करने
ही करने हैं। ठीक है? क्योंकि फिशिंग ईमेल
पे क्लिक किया है। हो सकता है वहां
क्रेडेंशियल्स उसके चले गए हो। तो
क्रेडेंशियल्स को रिसेट करना है। देन
सिस्टम को आइसोलेट तब करना है अगर नेसेसरी
है। अगर ऐसा लगता है कि बड़े लेवल पे मास
स्केल पे हुआ कुछ ऐसा आइसोलेट करके ही
होगा तो आपको सिस्टम को आइसोलेट करना है।
अदरवाइज इसकी जरूरत नहीं है। एंड पॉइंट
यानी जो भी आपका लैपटॉप मशीन जो भी आपका
सर्वर है उसको स्कैन करना है और रिव्यूज
करने हैं लॉग्स को। लॉग्स जो है उसको
रिव्यूज करने हैं भैया कि भैया आखिर उसमें
कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें मिल रही हैं कि
नहीं। इससे आपका कंप्लीट प्रोसेस हो जाता
है। ठीक है? तो कुछ लोगों ने बिल्कुल सही
आंसर करा है यहां पे।
कि जिन्होंने आइसोलेशन और क्रेडेंशियल
रिसेट का बोला है बिल्कुल सही आंसर आपका।
बहुत अच्छी बात है। चलिए आप यहां तक सोच
पा रहे हैं। दिस इज़ वन ऑफ़ द ग्रेटेस्ट
थिंग। दिस इज़ वन ऑफ़ द बेस्ट थिंग मैं
मानूंगा कि आप अगर यहां तक सोच भी पा रहे
हैं तो। ठीक है? ओके। द थर्ड क्वेश्चन इज़
व्हाई डू अटैकर्स एस्केलेट प्रिविलेजेस
आफ्टर इनिशियल एक्सेस? इसका बहुत आंसर
सिंपल है। व्हाई डू अटैकर्स एस्केलेट
प्रिविलेजेस आफ्टर इनिशियल एक्सेस? बिकॉज़
सिंपल सा फंडा है। क्यों करते हैं? टू हाई
वैल्यू एसेट्स तक पहुंचने के लिए क्योंकि
हो सकता है इनिशियल एक्सेस में उनको लो
लेवल के एक्सेस मिले हो। उनको लो लेवल के
फाइल्स या अ लो लेवल के एसेट्स मिले हो
जिनमें उनको ज्यादा इनेशन ना हो। यही होता
है। राइट? राइट? हां बिल्कुल गेट द हाई
वैल्यू। तो हायर प्रिविलेज अलाउ अटैकर्स
टू डिसेबल सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स एंड
एक्सेस
सेंसिटिव सिस्टम्स। ठीक है? जो हाई वैल्यू
सिस्टम्स हैं उनको एक्सेस करता है। तो
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन यहां पे एस्केलेट
प्रिविलेज क्यों करता है? तो हायर
प्रिविलेज अलाउ अटैकर्स टू डिसेबल
सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स। ये आपको बोल देना
है क्योंकि सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स इज़ द वन
ऑफ़ द मेजर थिंग एंड एक्सेस हाई
वैल्यू सिस्टम्स। हाई वैल्यू
एरियाज़ या हाई वैल्यू या सेंसिटिव
सिस्टम्स या हाई वैल्यू सिस्टम्स या दूसरे
जो हाई वैल्यू सिस्टम्स हैं। आप दोनों में
से कोई भी मेंशन कर सकते हो। इट डज़ंट
मैटर। तो या तो सेंसिटिव सिस्टम या हाई
वैल्यू सिस्टम कुछ भी आप कर दीजिएगा।
दैट्स इट। हाई वैल्यू या एसेट्स लिख
दीजिए। एसेट्स भी लिख एसेट लिखेंगे और भी
ज्यादा अच्छा लगेगा। यू कैन पुट ऑन देयर।
ओके? उसके बाद आता है हाउ डू यू
डिफरेंशिएट बिटवीन फॉल्स पॉजिटिव एंड रियल
इंसिडेंट। अब इसको कैसे आप डिफरेंशिएट
करेंगे? फॉल्स पॉजिटिव एंड रियल इंसिडेंट
में। तो यहां देखिए कैसे डिेंशिएट करेंगे?
कोरिलेट लॉग्स चेक कॉन्टेक्स्ट एनालाइज
यूजर बिहेवियर एंड वैलिडेट द एक्टिविटी
इससे आप डिफरेंशिएट करेंगे कि भैया कौन सा
फर्स्ट पॉजिटिव है कौन सा रियल इंसिडेंट
है तो आप लॉग्स को कोरिलेट करेंगे लॉग्स
को चेक करेंगे रिलेट करेंगे कॉन्टेक्स्ट
चेक करेंगे एनालाइज़ करेंगे बिहेवियर यूजर
का एंड अकाउंट एंड वैलिडिटी जो वैलिडेट है
वो करेंगे एक्टिविटी को उसकी एक्टिविटी को
वैलिडेट करेंगे इससे आप डिफरेंस पता चला
लगा सकते हैं फॉल्स पॉजिटिव एंड रियल
इंसिडेंट के बीच में नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन
क्वेश्चन इज़ व्हाट लॉक्स शुड बी चेक
ड्यूरिंग अ ब्रूट फ़ोर्स इन्वेस्टिगेशन?
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स इन्वेस्टिगेशन में कौन से
लॉक्स चेक होने चाहिए? इसका आंसर दीजिए आप
लोग।
बताइए। इसका आंसर दीजिए। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
इन्वेस्टिगेशन में कौन सी लॉस चेक होने
चाहिए?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए कुछ लोगों का आंसर यहां पे बता देते
हैं। यहां पे ब्रूटf अटैक में यहां पे
Windows सिक्योरिटी लॉक्स ऑथेंटिकेशन
लॉक्स वीपीए लॉक्स फायर लॉग्स एंड एसआई
अलर्ट एसआईएम अलर्ट्स सारी चीजें चेक होनी
चाहिए। क्योंकि ब्रूटf अटैक पासवर्ड के
ऊपर पासवर्ड अटैक है एक तरह का जहां पे
पासवर्ड को ब्रूट फ़ोर्स करके पासवर्ड
स्क्रै करने की कोशिश की जाती है। तो उसके
लॉक्स Windows के सिक्योरिटी लॉ्स में भी
आएंगे। ऑथेंटिकेशन लॉ्स में भी आएंगे।
वीpए लॉक्स में भी आ सकते हैं। फायरवल
लॉक्स में भी अगर कोई वीpए क्रेडेंशियल
है, फायरवल क्रिएशियल्स है उसमें भी आ
सकते हैं या जो भी इनबाउट आउटबाउट आपका
कनेक्शन है एंड एसआईएम अलर्ट्स को भी आप
जो है वो चेक करते हैं या इन्वेस्टिगेट
करते हैं। तो ये एक प्रॉपर आंसर हो सकता
है जहां पे आप विंडो सिक्योरिटी लॉक्स,
वीपीए लॉक्स, ऑथेंटिकेशन लॉक्स, फायर
लॉग्स एंड एसआईएम अलर्ट्स को जो है
इन्वेस्टिगेट करते हैं। ये जो आपकी थी
एनालिस्ट थिंकिंग वाली थी आपकी। अब यहां
पे ये आपके आंसर कीज़ है। इसके ऊपर अब ये
तो हमने ऑलरेडी डिस्कस कर लिया है। अब
इसको मैं यहां पे रहने देता हूं। एंड
लेट्स
लीव इट। ठीक है? यहां पे ये आपका एनालिस
थिंकिंग कंप्लीट हो जाता है।
चलिए
अब यहां पे मैं कुछ और चीज पे आता हूं।
हम
अब यहां पे हम
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब मैं यहां
पे आपको अ कुछ सिनेरियो दूंगा। उस
सिनेरियो में आपको आंसर करना है। ठीक है?
आपको आंसर करना है। सिंपल सा सिनेरियो है।
मैं इसको और थोड़ा सा जूम कर देता हूं। सो
दैट आपको आंसर जल्दी ना दिखे।
आपके लिए है तो प्लीज आप इसके अकॉर्डिंग
आंसर कीजिएगा या इसका मैं सिंपल
अ क्वेश्चंस एक बार देख लेता हूं अगर इफ
क्वेश्चंस ओनली है तो
हां ये आंसर सही है इस तरीके ये इस पे मैं
करता हूं आपसे
हम चलिए चलिए
हम
सो यहां पे सिनेरियो है। ठीक है? ये
सिनेरियो पे हम लेके चलते हैं। राइट?
सिनेरियो वन है आपका ऑथेंटिकेशन लॉग
एनालिसिस का। एसआईएम में आपके एक अलर्ट
आता है। अलर्ट का नेम है मल्टीपल फेल्ड
लॉगिन अटेम्प्ट्स। सोर्स आईपी आपको यहां
पे एक इस तरीके की दिखती है। टारगेट यूजर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर है। इवेंट आईडी 4625 आपको
दिखती है। अटेमप्ट्स 320 अटेम्प्ट्स हैं।
टाइम विंडो 4 मिनट्स का आ रहा है। व्हाट
व्हाट टाइप ऑफ़ अटैक इज़ लाइकली अकरिंग? तो
यहां पे ऑप्शन ए है। क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग,
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स, फिशिंग एंड एस्सक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन। सो, व्हाट इज़ द आंसर? इसका आंसर
बहुत ईजी है। ये ऑब्वियस सी बात है।
मल्टीपल फेल्ड लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट्स हैं।
फेल्ड लॉग इन क्यों? इवेंट आईडी 4625 इज़ द
फेल्ड लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट। हमने पहले भी देखा
था। एंड यहां पे मैंने मैंने आपको पहले भी
पूछा था कि 4625 इवेंट आईडी कौन सी होती
है? तो फेल लॉग इन का होता है। यहां पे
मल्टीपल फेल लॉगिन अटेम्प्ट्स हैं। तो जब
मल्टीपल फेल लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट्स हो रहे हैं
तो ये एक टाइप का ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक जो है
वो आपका कहलाएगा। दिस इज़ कॉल्ड ब्रूटोस
अटैक। राइट? चलिए अब आते हैं नेक्स्ट
क्वेश्चन पे।
हां, नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ व्हिच लॉग फील्ड
इंडिकेट्स द अटैकर्स सोर्स? कौन सा लॉग
फील्ड अटैकर्स के सोर्स को इंडिकेट करता
है? इसका आंसर बताइए आप लोग। ए में अकाउंट
नेम, बी सोर्स नेटवर्क एड्रेस, इवेंट आईडी
या लॉग इन टाइप कौन सा है? ए, बी, सी, डी
बताइए।
अकस सोर्स को बताता है। अकाउंट नेम, सोर्स
नेटवर्क एड्रेस जो ऊपर में सोर्स नेटवर्क
एड्रेस यहां पे
यह जो सोर्स आईपी है, उसकी बात यहां पे हम
कर रहे हैं। सोर्स आईपी, सोर्स नेटवर्क
एड्रेस वही होता है आपका। ऑब्वियस सी बात
है। इवेंट आईडी या लॉग ऑन टाइप कौन सा है?
ऑब्वियस सी बात है। इट्स आंसर इज़ सोर्स
नेटवर्क एड्रेस जो इंडिकेट अटैकर्स के
सोर्स को इंडिकेट करता है। अटैकर कहां से
ऑपरेट कर रहा है? तो इसका आंसर ऑब्वियस सी
बात है। सोर्स नेटवर्क एड्रेस होगा बी
होगा। ठीक है? तो ये आंसर होगा इसका बी।
नेक्स्ट आते हैं यहां पे। व्हाट डज़ इवेंट
आईडी 4625 रिप्रेजेंट? ये मैंने पहले भी
पूछा था आपसे। अगेन यहां पे रिपीट हो रहा
है। सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन फेल लॉग इन अकाउंट
क्रिएशन पासवर्ड चेंज्ड। बताइए क्या होगा?
सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन फेल्ड लॉग इन अकाउंट
क्रिएशन, पासवर्ड चेंज। ए, बी, सी, डी
ऑब्वियस सी बात है। इसका आंसर है बी। तो
फेल्ड लॉगिन अटेप्ट। चलिए बहुत अच्छी बात
है।
अब यहां पे एक और क्वेश्चन है। व्हाट शुड
द एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट चेक नेक्स्ट? नेक्स्ट
क्या चेक करना चाहिए? सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन
इवेंट्स 4624 वाला ईमेल लॉग्स
फायरवल फॉर्म फॉर्म फायरवल फॉर्मवेयर या
डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स अब बताइए कौन सा चेक
करना चाहिए अटैकर को नेक्स्ट इसके बाद
सक्सेसफुल लॉगिन इवेंट्स ईमेल लॉग्स फायर
फॉर्म
या फिर
डीएनएस रिकॉर्ड्स
बता दीजिए
आंसर ए बोल रहे हैं सभी सभी लोग बिल्कुल
सही अच्छी बात है। नेक्स्ट जो है इसको यूज़
देखना चाहिए। देखना चाहिए चेक करना चाहिए
ऐसे सिनेरियो में सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन
इवेंट्स को कि भैया कोई सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन
इवेंट्स तो नहीं हुआ है। फेल लॉग इन
अटेम्प्ट्स तो हो रहे हैं बट अगर
सक्सेसफुल लॉग इन अटेम्प्ट्स हुए होंगे तो
फिर ये प्रॉब्लमेटिक है। फिर ये तो दिक्कत
वाली बात है। फिर तो इन्वेस्टिगेशन और
ज्यादा तगड़ा करना पड़ेगा क्योंकि एक लॉग
इन सक्सेसफुल हो चुका है ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक
में। इसका मतलब अकाउंट कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुआ
है भाई। है ना? राइट? तो इट्स आंसर इज़ ए।
अब यहां पे दूसरा सिनेरियो है। सिनेरियो
इज़
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
सस्पिशियस लॉग इन अलर्ट का सिनेरियो है।
एसआईएम अलर्ट क्या आता है? यूजर zone. है
डीओई प्रीवियस लॉग इन इंडिया में है। न्यू
लॉग इन रशिया में है। टाइम डिफरेंस 2
मिनट्स का है। ऑथेंटिकेशन ओ 365 ऑफिस 365
का ऑथेंटिकेशन है। व्हाट सिक्योरिटी
इंडिकेटर डज़ दिस रिप्रेजेंट? कौन सा
सिक्योरिटी इंडिकेटर ये रिप्रेजेंट करता
है? पहला है इंपॉसिबल ट्राइवल। सेकंड है
फिशिंग। थर्ड है सी मालवेयर एंड डी इज़
डेटा एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन। सो व्हाट इज़ द आंसर?
द आंसर शुड बी ए इंपॉसिबल ट्रेवल क्योंकि
इंडिया से रशिया 2 मिनट में कैसे भी नहीं
पहुंचा जा सकता है। बिल्कुल सही आंसर है।
आंसर जिन्होंने भी ए बोला है बिल्कुल
एब्सोलुटली करेक्ट। बहुत अच्छी बात है। अब
यहां पे नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ व्हाट अटैक
माइट हैव हैपेंड बिफोर दिस लॉग इन? इस
लॉगिन के पहले कौन सा अटैक हुआ होगा?
फिशिंग और क्रेडेंशियल थप्ट हार्डवेयर
फेलर डीएनएस मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन सॉफ्टवेयर
अपडेट ए बी सी डी बताइए वि टाइप ऑफ अटैक
शुड हैव बीन डन बिफोर दिस पर्टिकुलर
इंपॉसिबल ट्रेवल वाला सिनेरियो
हां एकदम सही ए फिशिंग और क्रेडेंशियल
थ्रेफ्ट हुआ होगा बिल्कुल क्योंकि
क्रेडेंशियल थफ्ट्ट या फिशिंग हुई होगी
तभी तो यह बच्चा लॉगिन कर पा रहा है कहीं
और से सो बिल्कुल सही आंसर है जिन्होंने
भी आंसर दिया है ए उनका नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन
इज़ व्हाट शुड द एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट चेक
इमीडिएटली क्या चेक करना चाहिए? ए लॉग इन
हिस्ट्री एंड आईपी रेपुटेशन बी सीपीू
टेंपरेचर सी प्रिंटर लॉक्स डी मॉनिटर
रेोल्यूशन। बताइए इसका एसओसी को तुरंत
क्या चेक करना चाहिए ऐसे सिनेरियो में? ए
बी सी डी
बताइए बताइए। ए काफी लोग आंसर कर रहे हैं
ए अच्छी बात है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके मेनी पीपल आर डूइंग सेइंग ए आंसर
बिल्कुल सही आंसर शुड बी ए क्योंकि लॉग इन
हिस्ट्री एंड आईपी रेपुटेशन चेक करना
चाहिए कि भैया लॉग इन कहां-कहां से हुआ है
और जहां से लॉग इन हुआ है जिस आईपी से
उसकी रेपुटेशन क्या है? राइट? नेक्स्ट
क्वेश्चन फ्रॉम दिस सिनेरियो इज़
व्हाट इमीडिएट रिस्पांस एक्शन शुड बी
टेकन? ए इग्नोर अलर्ट, बी फोर्स पासवर्ड
रिसेट एंड रिवोक सेशन, सी रिस्टार्ट
राउटर, डी डिलीट द यूजर अकाउंट। बताइए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बताइए, जल्दी बताइए फटाफट। व्हाट इमीडिएट
रिस्पांस एक्शन शुड बी टेकन? ए इग्नोर
अलर्ट, बी फोर्स पासवर्ड रिसेट एंड रिवोक
सेशन, सी रिस्ट
राउटर, डी डिलीट यूजर अकाउंट। आंसर बताइए।
आंसर फोर्स पासवर्ड रिसेट एंड रिवोक्सेशन।
बिल्कुल सही आंसर है। द आंसर इज़ एंड शुड
बी बी ओनली इसका मतलब होता है कि फोर्स
पासवर्ड रिसेट तो करना ही है क्योंकि
लॉगिन हो चुका है। एंड सेशन रिवोक यानी
रशिया से जो लॉगिन हुई होगी उसको रिवोक
करना है। राइट? तो आंसर इज़ बी। बिल्कुल
सही है। ठीक है? अब नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन पे
चलते हैं। सिनेरियो थ्री। इस सिनेरियो में
आते हैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ईमेल सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट का सिनेरियो ईमेल
गेटवे अलर्ट क्या आता है? सेंडर कौन है?
सिक्योरिटी
hfन अपडेट@ microsoft hf su.com रिसिपिएंट
कौन है? hr@ compनी.com अटैचमेंट क्या है?
सैलरी एडजस्टमेंट 2025.xls
एसपीएफ फेल है। डीकेआईएम फेल है।
डीएमआईआरसी फेल है। व्हाट टाइप ऑफ़ अटैक इज़
दिस? ए फिशिंग बी रसमवेयर सी डी डी ओएस डी
ब्रूड फोर्स बताइए वि टाइप ऑफ अटैक इज दिस
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अगर देखा जाए थोड़ा सोचा जाए तो आंसर यह है
फिशिंग अटैक है। ऑब्वियस सी बात है।
क्यों? क्योंकि आप देखो सेंडर कौन है?
सिक्योरिटी अपडेट माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
एस के बाद ओ ये कौन सा ओ है भाई? दिस इज़
नॉट ओ। दिस इज़ नॉट ओ। समझ में आया? तो ये
ओ नहीं है। जीरो वाला ओ है ये। तो एक गलत
यहां पे डोमेन है। ऑब्वियस सी बात है।
एचआर को भेजा है। सैलरी एडजस्टमेंट
क्योंकि सभी लोग इसको खोलेंगे। एसपीएफ
सेंडर पॉलिसी फ्रेमवर्क ये फेल है। एसपीएफ
की सेटिंग नहीं है यहां पे। ठीक है?
डीकेएम भी फेल है। ये सब नहीं है। तो
ऑब्वियस सी बात है इसका ये एक फिशिंग अटैक
हो सकता है। नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ इसी पे
बेस्ड है। व्हिच इंडिकेटर सजेस्ट द सजेस्ट
द ईमेल इज़ मलिशियस? कौन सा इंडिकेटर
सजेस्ट करेगा कि ईमेल मलशियस है? एसपीएफ,
डीके, आईएम, डीएमए, आरसी फेलियर, करेक्ट
ग्रामर,
नॉन सेंडर, इंटरनल ईमेल। बताइए इसका आंसर
क्या है?
बताइए इसका आंसर क्या है?
एसपीएफ डीके आईएम डीएमआई आरसी फेलियर्स
करेक्ट ग्रामर नोन सेंडर इंटरनल ईमेल तो
देखो इंटरनल ईमेल नोन सेंडर ये सब तो खैर
होना नहीं है। करेक्ट ग्रामर और एसकेएफ डी
एसपीएफ डीके आईएम डीएमआरसी फेलियर दो
ऑप्शंस जो है यहां पे लग रहे हैं
प्रॉमिनेंट। आप बताइए अब दोनों में से ए
या बी? लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी ऑफ़ यू आर सेइंग
ए एंड हाउ मेनी ऑफ़ यू आर सेइंग बी। लेट्स
सी एंड व्हिच इज़ गोइंग टू बी करेक्ट।
कुछ लोग बी बोल रहे हैं मैक्सिमम लोग। कुछ
लोग बी बोल रहे हैं मैक्सिमम लोग। ए बोल
रहे हैं तो इसका आंसर ए है। एसपीएफ डीके
आईएम फेलियर्स। ऐसा इसलिए क्योंकि जो
इंडिकेटर्स है उसमें ये चीज़ लिखी ये चीज़
लगाई गई रहती है कि एसपीएफ, डीकेआईएम और
डीएमआरसी अगर फेलियर हो रहे हैं तीनों में
से तो उस केस में यह जो है मलेशिया फीमेल
के कैटेगरी में जाता है। ग्रामर करेक्ट का
कोई इंडिकेटर ऐसा इसलिए नहीं होगा क्योंकि
वह फॉल्स पॉजिटिव भी दिखाएगा। हो सकता है
कई लोग इंटेंशनली मतलब इंटेंशनली नहीं कई
लोग नॉर्मल जो मैसेज अ
ईमेल करते हैं तो उसमें ग्रामेटिकली
मिस्टेक कर देते हैं। ऐसा होता है। कई बार
ईमेल्स आते हैं तो ग्रामेटिकली मिस्टेक्स
पॉसिबल है। हो सकता है। तो उस केस में ये
भी आंसर बिल्कुल नहीं होगा। नहीं तो वो
फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स को बार-बार देगा कि हां
यहां ग्रामेटिकल मिस्टेक है तो ये मलिशियस
है। इस वजह से एसपीएफ डी के आई एम एलएमसी
करना बिल्कुल परफेक्ट है। हां हम इसमें
अगर ऐसा कोई अलर्ट लगा देते इस टाइप का
कुछ अलर्ट लगाते कि डोमेन के अंदर कोई अगर
ग्रामेटिकल मिस्टेक है तो अलर्ट देने का
तो वो ठीक है। वो फिर चलेगा कि डोमेन के
अंदर करने लेकिन अगर सीधा करेक्ट ग्रामर
है मतलब बॉडी में भी हो सकती है कहीं भी
हो सकती है। सो दिस शुड नॉट बी देयर। सो ए
इज द ऑप्शन एसपीएफ डीके आई एम डीएमआरसी
फेलियर बात समझ में आ गई सभी लोगों को
सभी लोग समझ में आ रहा है ये सभी लोग समझ
में आई ये चीज सभी को
या गॉट इट
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
बहुत अच्छी बात है चलिए अच्छी बात है वेरी
गुड अब आते हैं नेक्स्ट सिनेरियो
क्वेश्चंस पे व्हाट रिस्क डज़ द डॉट एक्सेल
एसएम अटैचमेंट इंडिकेट क्या रिस्क यह
डिनोट करता है? इमेज फाइल, माइक्रोबेस
मैलवेयर, वीडियो फाइल, ऑडियो फाइल बता
दीजिए।
आंसर ए, बी, सी, डी
बताइए। एक्सls अटैचमेंट क्या डिनोट करता
है?
थोड़ा सभी लोग बताइए
ताकि पता चले।
देखिए बिल्कुल सही आंसर है यहां पे। आंसर
इज़ बी माइक्रोबेस्ड मैलवेयर। क्यों?
क्योंकि देखो Microsoft Exl का जो
एक्सटेंशन होता है जनरली csv और डॉट
एक्सls होता है। राइट?
एक्सls होता है। बट एक्सls जो है यह
माइक्रो जो माइक्रो माइक्रो सॉरी गलती से
बोला माइक्रो नहीं माइक्रो बेस्ड जो
डॉक्यूमेंट्स होते हैं उनका एक्सटेंशन
एक्सls होता है आपके एक्सेल में। ठीक है?
Microsoft एक्सेल में जो माइक्रो बेस्ड
आपके डॉक्यूमेंट्स होते हैं। और माइक्रो
बेस्ड डॉक्यूमेंट्स में वलेबिलिटीज
आई है, एक्सप्लइट्स आए हैं। एंड दैट्स
व्हाई इट शोज़ द रिस्क।
ऑफ द अटैचमेंट रिस्क लेवल। तो इसका आंसर
बी होगा। ठीक है? जो कि माइक्रोबेस
मैलवेयर को डिनोट करता है। आंसर इज़ बी।
नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ व्हाट शुड
व्हाट शुड एसओसी डू इफ द यूजर ओपन द
अटैचमेंट? इग्नोर अलर्ट, आइसोलेट एंड
पॉइंट एंड स्कैन सिस्टम, डिलीट ईमेल ओनली,
डिसेबल Wi-Fi। यह बहुत आसान आंसर होने
वाला है। अलर्ट तो करेगा नहीं। इग्नोर
इग्नोर तो करेगा नहीं अलर्ट को। ईमेल्स को
डिलीट करने से कोई फायदा नहीं है। वाई-फाई
डिसेबल करके क्या होगा? तो ऑब्वियस सी बात
है एक ऑप्शन बचता है बी आंसर। आइसोलेट एंड
पॉइंट एंड स्कैन द सिस्टम। इट्स अ वेरी
ईजी आंसर कि एंड पॉइंट को आइसोलेट कीजिए
भैया और सिस्टम को स्कैन कीजिए। आंसर इज़
बी। सिनेरियो फोर में यहां पे अब आते हैं
एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट। एंड पॉइंट
सिक्योरिटी अलर्ट में आते हैं थोड़ा सा। और
यहां देखते हैं ईडीआर अलर्ट का सीन यहां
पे है। उसमें आते हैं। ईडीआर में क्या है?
[खांसने की आवाज़]
होस्ट आपका एचआर लैपटॉप 14 है। प्रोसेस
micad.exe है। टारगेट प्रोसेस एलs.exe है।
व्हाट अटैक टेक्निक इज बीइंग यूज़्ड? कौन
सा अटैक टेक्निक यहां पे यूज़ हुआ है? ए बी
सी डी क्रेडेंशियल जंपिंग एस्क्यू
इंजेक्शन क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग डीडीओएस
बता दीजिए। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
आंसर बताइए कौन सा है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम
बहुत अच्छी बात है
आंसर इज़ ए बहुत अच्छी बात है क्रेडेंशियल
डंपिंग इट्स इजी आंसर क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग
ही होती है जिसमें कि अटैक टेक्निक्स
मिमिक्स का यूज़ किया जाता है मिड का यूज़
करके क्रेडेंशियल्स को डंप किए जाते हैं।
राइट? बिल्कुल सही आंसर। नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन
इज़ और बेस्ड ऑन दिस पर्टिकुलर सिनेरियो
व्हाट सेंसिटिव डाटा इज़ अटैकर ट्राइंग टू
एक्सट्रैक्ट? कौन सा सेंसिटिव डेटा अटैकर
ट्राई कर रहा है एक्सट्रैक्ट करने का? ए
है पासवर्ड हैशेस एंड करबेरॉस टिकट्स।
इमेजज़ वीडियो फाइल्स, प्रिंटर ड्राइवर्स।
बहुत सिंपल है। इस आंसर बहुत सिंपल है। इट
शुड बी पासवर्ड हैशेस एंड करबेरॉस टिकट्स।
राइट? यह मैंने पहले ही बताया था। ए आंसर
है। कौन सा सेंसिटिव डाटा चुराएगा? तो भाई
इमेज, वीडियोस, प्रिंटर थोड़ी ना चुराएगा।
प्रिंटर ड्राइवर्स पासवर्ड हैश चुराने की
कोशिश करता है अ कन्वेंशियल स्टफिंग में।
नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़
ओके।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
व्हिच वि W वि W वि W वि W वि W वि W वि W
वि W वि W वि Windows प्रोसेस स्टोर्स
ऑथेंटिकेशन क्रेडेंशियल्स? ये भी आपसे
पहले डील हो चुकी है। इसका आंसर आपको आना
आना चाहिए। एक्सप्लोरर.ex.xe,
Notepad.ex, Chrome.xec बता दीजिए इसका
आंसर। ऑब्वियस सी बात है इसका आंसर
एल्स.exe
होगा जो कि पासवर्ड अ ऑथेंटिकेशन के
क्रेडेंशियल्स को स्टोर करने के लिए यूज़
में ली जाती है एलs.ex। राइट? नेक्स्ट इज़
व्हाट अटैक स्टेजेस मे फॉलो दिस
एक्टिविटी। व्हाट अटैक स्टेजेस मे फॉलो
दिस एक्टिविटी। पहला है प्रिविलेज
एस्क्लेशन एंड लैटरल मूवमेंट। दूसरा है
बैकअप ऑपरेशन। तीसरा है सॉफ्टवेयर अपडेट।
चौथा है सिस्टम रिबूूट। बताइए व्हाट अटैक
स्टेज मे फॉलो दिस एक्टिविटी। इस
एक्टिविटी को कौन सा स्टेज जो है फॉलो कर
सकता है? तो इसका आंसर है क्योंकि जब जब
एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी की बात हो रही है
एंड जब मेमिकाह टूल से क्रेडेंशियल्स डंप
कर दिए गए हैं तो इसके आगे क्या हो सकता
है? क्रेडेंशियल्स डंप कर दिए गए पासवर्ड
मिल गए हैं। तो प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन एंड
लैटरल मूवमेंट जैसी प्रोसेससेस हो सकती
हैं। तो बंदा जो है अटैकर जो है प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेट करेगा। लैटरल मूवमेंट करेगा
नेटवर्क के अंदर में। एक सिस्टम से दूसरे
सिस्टम में हाई वैल्यू एसेट्स तक पहुंचने
की कोशिश करेगा। यही तो काम करेगा। तो
इसको इसका आंसर है ए। नाउ सिनेरियो फाइव
इज़ देयर। लैटरल मूवमेंट अलर्ट में आएगा।
अब इसमें हम आते हैं। लैटरल मूवमेंट अलर्ट
में क्या है? एसआईएम अलर्ट है। एसआईएम
अलर्ट सोर्स होस्ट क्या है? एचआर लैपटॉप
है। डेस्टिनेशन होस्ट फाइल सर्वर टू है।
प्रोटोकॉल आरडीपी यूज़ हो रही है।
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर है। टाइम है 3:12 am
रात के 32 am रात को। ठीक है? अब इसके
आंसर पे आते हैं। क्वेश्चन पे आते हैं।
व्हाट
अटैक फेस डस दिस इंडिकेट? कौन सा अटैक फेज
है यह? लैटरल मूवमेंट, फिशिंग, डाटा
बैकअप, सिस्टम पाथ ए, बी, सी, डी। बताइए
कौन सा है?
बताइए।
व्हाट इज द आंसर? व्हाट अटैक फेज डज़ दिस
इंडिकेट? यह कौन सा अटैक फेज है? जहां पे
एसआईएम अलर्ट में आपका सोर्स होस्ट एचआर
लैपटॉप होता है। डेस्टिनेशन होस्ट फाइल
सर्वर की होस्ट होती है। आरडीपी प्रोटोकॉल
का यूज़ किया जाता है। एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर
होता है रात को 3:00 बजे के आसपास 3:1 की
ये चीज़ है। इसका आंसर सिंपल सा है। ए होगा
लैटरल मूवमेंट क्योंकि एक लोकेशन से दूसरे
लोकेशन में सिस्टम के अंदर मतलब जा रहा
है। तो इसको हम लैटरल मूवमेंट कहते हैं।
देन द नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ व्हाई दिस इज़
व्हाई इज़ दिस लॉग इन सस्िशियस? ये लॉग इन
सस्िशियस क्यों है भाई? तो एडमिन अकाउंट
यूज्ड फ्रॉम यूजर वर्क स्टेशन, नॉर्मल
बिज़नेस एक्टिविटी, शेड्यूल टास्क, सिस्टम
अपडेट। क्यों ये सस्िशियस है? बताइए।
व्हाट इज द आंसर?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तो, इसका आंसर होगा एडमिन अकाउंट यूज्ड
फॉर फ्रॉम यूजर वर्क स्टेशन। इसका आंसर
बिल्कुल यही होगा। सस्िशियस इसीलिए है
क्योंकि इस अलॉट में आपने देखा होगा कि
यूजर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर है बट बट यूजर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर है बट यहां पे क्या है
एचआर लैपटॉप है ये एचआर लैपटॉप को यूज़
किया जा रहा है जो कि एक नॉर्मल यूजर
लैपटॉप है बट एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर है तो
यहां पे फिर ये थोड़ी सी सस्पिशियस वाली जो
चीज़ है वो निकल कर आती है तो यहां पे
ऑब्वियस सी बात है एडमिन अकाउंट यूज़्ड
फ्रॉम यूजर वर्क स्टेशन ये है 18 का आंसर
आपका ठीक है आई थिंक आप समझ गए होंगे इसका
आंसर ए है। नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ देयर।
नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ व्हाट प्रीवियस अटैक
लाइकली इनेबल्ड दिस? कौन सा प्रीवियस अटैक
इस चीज को इनेबल किया होगा? इस चीज को
एग्जीक्यूट किया होगा? क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग
और फिशिंग, हार्डवेयर फेलियर, डीएनएस
अपडेट, एंटीवायरस स्कैन। बताइए। इसका भी
आंसर बिल्कुल ईजी है। सभी लोग आंसर कर
पाएंगे। हां क्रेडनेंशियल डंपिंग या
फिशिंग हुई होगी तभी यह जो अटैक है लेटरल
मूवमेंट वाली यह पॉसिबल हो सकती है। तो
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग या फिशिंग हुई होगी।
राइट? ए इज़ द करेक्ट आंसर। नेक्स्ट
क्वेश्चन इज़ व्हाट लॉग शुड एसओसी
इन्वेस्टिगेट नेक्स्ट? कौन सा लॉग एसओसी
को इन्वेस्टिगेट करना चाहिए? तो Windows
सिक्योरिटी लॉग, म्यूजिक फाइल्स, प्रिंटर
लॉक्स, मॉनिटर सेटिंग्स।
राइट? इसका भी आंसर ए है। Windows
सिक्योरिटी लॉक्स। राइट? क्योंकि यहां पे
भैया यहां पे यहां पे क्या हुआ है हमारा
लैटरल मूवमेंट एक्ट हुआ है। तो जब इस
तरीके की एक्ट हो तो विंडो सिक्योरिटी
लॉग्स को ही यहां पे चेक किया जाता है।
आंसर इज़ ए तो व्हाट शुड व्हाट लॉक शुड बी
इन्वेस्टिगेटेड? तो ए कौन सा है भैया?
विंडो सिक्योरिटी लॉक्स। ठीक है? दैट्स
इट। सिनेरियो सिक्स में अब आते हैं डाटा
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन अलर्ट। अब इसमें क्या है?
मैं आपको बता देता हूं।
अब डाटा एक्सपिल्ट्रेशन अलॉट में आते हैं
एंड देखते हैं इसमें फायर लॉग है एक फायर
लॉग में सोर्स आईपी है यह डेस्टिनेशन IP
है ये प्रोटोकॉल एचटीटीपीएस है डेटा
ट्रांसफर 4.8 GB का है टाइम 241 am का है
होस्ट जो है वो फाइनेंस पीसी है अब सोचो
फाइनेंस पीसी है जहां से 4.8 GB की डाटा
ट्रांसफर हो रही है। सोर्स आईपी यानी जो
होस्ट की IP है वो इनका इंटरनल IPपी है।
बट डेस्टिनेशन आईपी नेटवर्क के बाहर का
आईपी है। आउटबाउंड कनेक्शन है। जो उसका
इंटरनल आईपी है वो तो है नहीं। ये नेटवर्क
के बाहर का आईपी है। यानी नेटवर्क के बाहर
एक सिस्टम एक नेटवर्क के बाहर 4.8 GB का
डाटा एचटीटीपीएस प्रोटोकॉल के थ्रू भेजा
जा रहा है फाइनेंस वाले पीसी से रात को
2:30.5 के आसपास 240 के आसपास। यह बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग है। व्हाट सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी
कुड दिस रिप्रेजेंट? कौन सा सस्िशियस
एक्टिविटी ये रिप्रेजेंट कर सकता है? ए बी
सी डी बहुत ईजी आंसर है। बताइए मुझे। मेरा
काम है यहां पे सिनेरियो प्रोवाइड करना।
मेरा देखो आंसर्स तो आपको ईजी मिल रहे
होंगे। बहुत सारे केसेस में आपको आंसर्स
ईजी दिख रहे होंगे। बट यहां पे मेरा मोटिव
आपको आंसर ईजी प्रोवाइड करने से नहीं है।
मेरा मोटिव है आपको सिनेरियो समझाना और
उसके बेस पे आंसर्स के आपके दिमाग में फिट
करना ताकि आप नेक्स्ट टाइम कभी भी ऐसी
सिचुएशन में आएंगे तो आप उस चीज को कितना
भी कॉम्प्लेक्स सिचुएशन क्रिएट करके आपको
दिया जाएगा ना आप समझ जाएंगे कि
एग्जैक्टली हो क्या रहा है। तो वही चीज़ है
यहां पे। द आंसर इज़ ए डेटा
एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन। यहां से डेटा चुराया जा
रहा है। तो डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन इज़ द
आंसर। अब आते हैं यहां पे व्हाई इज द टाइम
ऑफ एक्टिविटीेंट? टाइम एक्टिविटी का क्यों
इंपॉर्टेंट है? आपने देखा होगा 241 am के
आसपास का टाइम है। रात को मतलब हो रहा है।
तो इसका आंसर है यहां पे ऑप्शंस हैं।
अकर्ड आउटसाइड नॉर्मल बिज़नेस आर सिस्टम
रिबूूट, हार्डवेयर चेक, प्रिंटर जॉब। तो
ऑब्वियस सी बात है इसका आंसर है अकर्ड
आउटसाइड नॉर्मल बिज़नेस आर। नॉर्मल बिज़नेस
आर अह के बाहर ये चीज हुई है तो सस्िशियस
भी है क्योंकि
अब रात को 3:00 बजे कौन डाटा ट्रांसफर
करता है? या सुबह के 3:00 बजे डाटा
ट्रांसफर कौन करेगा? और वो भी 4.8 GB वो
भी दूसरे नेटवर्क में। तो ऑब्वियस सी बात
है इट्स सस्िशियस। सो इट शुड बी
इन्वेस्टिगेटेड। अब आते हैं व्हाट शुड द
एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट इन्वेस्टिगेट नेक्स्ट?
अब भैया डाटा तो चली गई। तो अब एसओसी
एनालिस्ट क्या इन्वेस्टिगेट करेगा भैया?
पहला फाइल एक्सेस लॉक्स एंड यूजर
एक्टिविटी। दूसरा स्क्रीन ब्राइटनेस, माउस
ड्राइवर, कीबोर्ड सेटिंग। तो ऑब्वियस सी
बात है ये बाकी के तीनों ये बेकार के
ऑप्शंस हैं। कोई रिलेटेबल नहीं है। तो
इसका जो आंसर है फाइल एक्सेस लॉग्स एंड
यूजर एक्टिविटी। देखिएगा भैया फाइल एक्सेस
लॉग्स को चेक करेगा भैया कौन-कौन सी फाइल
गई है, क्या गया है, कहां गया है? ये सब
एंड यूजर की एक्टिविटी कि भैया इसने भैया
बंदे ने किया क्या है? एग्जैक्ट इसने कहां
भेजा? किस IPपी एड्रेस पे कनेक्ट करा?
क्या लॉगिन करा? कहां एक्सेस करा? क्या
करा? तो यूजर की एक्टिविटी और फाइल की
एक्टिविटी वो सब चेक करेगा। तो आंसर इज़ ए
दैट इज़ द फाइल एक्सेस लॉक्स एंड यूजर
एक्टिविटी। द नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन इज़ व्हाट
टाइप ऑफ़ इंसिडेंट माइट दिस बिकम? ये किस
टाइप का इंसिडेंट हो सकता है? डेटा ब्रच
हार्डवेयर इशू, प्रिंटर फेलियर, सॉफ्टवेयर
अपडेट। सो, इसका आंसर भी बहुत सिंपल सा है
कि डेटा ब्रीच इज़ द आंसर। डेटा ब्रीच कौन
सा है? डेटा ब्रीच इज़ द आंसर। राइट? इसका
आंसर क्या है? डेटा ब्रिज। क्यों? क्योंकि
यहां पे डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेट हो रही है। तो
इसका सिंपल सा आंसर है डेटा ब्रिज। दैट्स
इट। व्हाट टाइप ऑफ इंजीनियर माइट बिकम
डेटा ब्रिज? क्योंकि डेटा ब्रिज यहां पे
हो रही है। तो डेटा ब्रिज इज़ द आंसर। ए इज़
द आंसर। बिल्कुल सही। चलिए यहां पे ये
चीजें हो गई। अब ये सिनेरियो बेस्ड आपका
क्वेश्चंस भी आपका कंप्लीट हो चुका है।
यहां पे हमने इन चीजों को देख लिया। यहां
पे ये जो आंसर्स थे वही सारे ऑलमोस्ट आंसर
थे यहां पे। एंड जो हमने यहां पे डिस्कस
करें उसी के ये सारी चीजें। आंसर। ठीक है?
सो, यह सारे इंटरव्यू क्वेश्चंस एंड कुछ
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक्स पर हमने डिस्कशन करें।
इंपॉर्टेंट क्वेश्चंस को यहां पे हमने
देखे हैं। एंड
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आई थिंक
तो अभी आप सब ने देखा सब कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग
वे में काफी सारी चीजें आपने समझी हैं।
ठीक है? एंड इंटरव्यू्यूज के क्वेश्चंस
हमने देखे हैं। एंड इट वाज़ रियली अमेजिंग
अ टू अ
गो थ्रू दीज़ क्वेश्चंस। आप में से कई
लोगों ने काफी आंसर अच्छा करा। काफी अच्छे
से आंसर करा। कई लोगों का आंसर बिल्कुल
सही था। कुछ लोगों के आंसर गलत आ रहे थे।
उनको थोड़ा सा फोकस करने की और नीड है।
ट्रेनिंग को सिंसियरली फोकस करके
सिंसियरली करने की नीड है। एंड आप जैसे ही
आप और सिंसियर थोड़ा हो जाइएगा आप भी आप
आंसर कर पाइएगा। ये जो क्वेश्चंस थे ये
बहुत ही मैं आपको बता देता हूं यहां पे ये
जो मैंने क्वेश्चंस आपसे डील किए हैं ये
बहुत ही बेसिक क्वेश्चंस थे क्योंकि बेसिक
इसलिए थे क्योंकि अभी आप स्टार्ट कर रहे
हैं। अब इनके अंदर भी थोड़े से
कॉम्प्लेक्स क्वेश्चन भी बन सकते थे। बट
वो कॉम्प्लेक्स क्वेश्चंस मैं अगर लेकर
आऊंगा एंड अगर आपको मैंने बताया कि
कॉम्प्लेक्स क्वेश्चंस हैं ऐसा है और मैं
आपसे पूछूं तो उसमें से ज्यादा लोग आंसर
नहीं कर पाते और नहीं जब करेंगे तो आपको
डीमोटिवेशन होगी जो कि अभी के लेवल पे
बिल्कुल जरूरत नहीं है इसकी एक लेवल पे हो
सकता है आपको डीमोटिवेट
जानबूझ के किया जाएगा ताकि आप अंदर से फील
करो कि अरे यार मुझे और मेहनत करनी चाहिए।
अभी उसकी रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। अभी तो आप
स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं। तो बेसिक लेवल के
क्वेश्चंस मैंने आपके लिए प्रिपेयर करा
एंड आपके सामने लेकर आया। अब यहां से आपको
एक कॉन्फिडेंस मिला होगा एंड आपको समझ में
आया होगा कि जब आप एक ही टॉपिक के मल्टीपल
क्वेश्चंस को अलग-अलग तरीकों से डील करते
हैं तो आपका वो कांसेप्ट बिल्कुल क्लियर
होता है। दिमाग में आपके छप जाता है कि ये
चीज क्या करती है। अभी आपके दिमाग में
क्रेडेंशियल स्टफिंग, पासवर्ड स्प्रिंग,
ब्रूड फ़ोर्स मतलब ये सब ऐसे छप गया होगा
ना जैसे आज तक नहीं छपा होगा। मैं आपको
अगर आपको लग रहा है कि यह बात गलत है तो
बताइए आप मुझे कि नहीं सर ऐसा नहीं है।
सही है तो भी बताइए। अगर आपने जब आज
इंटरव्यू क्वेश्चंस करे हैं तो आपके दिमाग
में कुछ जो कांसेप्ट्स थे जो ऑलरेडी आपने
पढ़े तो होंगे बट आज आपके दिमाग में वो छप
जाएगा। छप गया होगा। अब वो जल्दी हटेगा
नहीं आपके दिमाग से। इंटरव्यू में जाएंगे
तो आप उसके अगेंस्ट उसके लिए बोल सकते
हैं। दिस इज़ द मेन थिंग दैट दिस अ
एक्चुअली अह अह वाज़ेंट फॉर यू ऑल। एंड
इंटरव्यूज़ से रिलेटेड क्वेश्चंस इंटरव्यू
अ फ्रेंडली क्वेश्चंस थे। इंटरव्यू में
ऐसे क्वेश्चंस इन टॉपिक से जो अभी के 10
क्लासेस हुए हैं उन्हीं के ये थे। बस याद
रखिएगा। राइट?
ये 10 क्लासेस जो थे उन्हीं उन्हीं के थे।
राइट?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलिए अब मैं यहां पे करता हूं यहां पे। अ
मजा आया गाइस?
चलिए मैंने एक पोल स्टार्ट किया है। सभी
लोग पोल पे आंसर कर दीजिए।
देखते हैं।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
गॉट इट?
हां। रिवीजन करने की जरूरत है। बिल्कुल
कीजिए। रिवीजन कीजिए।
बिल्कुल रिवीजन करने की जरूरत है थोड़े कुछ
लोगों की। बिल्कुल है।
थैंक यू अलबरूनी। थैंक यू सो मच ब्रदर।
ओके।
हां आज के बाद कांसेप्ट नहीं बोलेंगे।
बिल्कुल सही। या अबब्सोलुटली रुद्र
नहीं देखो एसओसी की रिमोट जॉब नहीं होगी।
हां अगर वो मैनेज्ड सर्विज यूज़ कर रहे हैं
कोई कंपनी मैनेज सर्विज जो मैंने आपको
बताया था एसओसी में तो रिमोट जॉब पॉसिबल
है। बट ऐसे रिमोट जॉब का कोई कांसेप्ट सीन
नहीं बैठ बैठता है। हां एसआईएम टूल्स पे
अगर आप रिमोटली काम तो कर ही सकते हो सब
कुछ लेकिन ऐसे रिमोट जॉब नहीं होता है।
रिमोट क्योंकि आप अलर्ट्स वगैरह को
एनालाइज़ करते हैं उस नेटवर्क के ऊपर वहीं
पे ऐसे करके कनेक्शन फिर बनानी पड़ती है।
फिर आपको कनेक्शन वो बाहर से देंगे कि
नहीं देंगे। दैट आल्सो मैटर्स राइट?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
वी हैव गॉट ऑल ऑफ फेम इन एकको प्रोग्राम
ग्रेट कांग्रेचुलेशंस रुद्र बहुत अच्छी
बात है अ थैंक्स सर फॉर ऑल द ऑल द सेशंस
या वेलकम
यू सर यू आर ग्रेट ट्रूली थैंक यू ब्रदर
मैं ग्रेट क्या हूं यार ग्रेट आप लोग
बनाते हो हम लोगों को ट्रेनर्स को टीचर्स
को मेंटर्स को
ओके
नेटवर्किंग आएगी यार आएगी नेटवर्किंग इसकी
बेसिक्स जितनी जरूरत है सब आएंगी
आई विल रिवाइज फुल्ली ऑन ऑल द वीडियोस
अगेन एनी एनी हाउ आई एम वर्किंग एज एसओसी
मैनेजर आई हैव ऑलरेडी आस्क्ड माय टीम
मेंबर्स टू गो थ्रू द वीडियो थैंक यू
प्रीतांबर थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर द
रिकमेंडेशन एंड एंड फॉर शेयरिंग वि देम।
दीज़ विल हेल्प अ लॉट एंड आई थिंक कि जब आप
शेयर करते हैं वीडियोस को लोगों को बताते
हैं तो इसमें हमारी हेल्प होती है एंड
लोगों तक पहुंचती है। मैं तो यही बोलूंगा।
अ
मैं सिंपल सा मैं डायरेक्ट बात करने में
ज्यादा बिलीव करता हूं। आप सबको मेरे बारे
में पता होगा ऑलरेडी कि व्यूज सबको चाहिए
होते हैं वीडियोस पे। सबको व्यूज चाहिए।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है। बट व्यूज के साथ-साथ
अगर क्वालिटी मिल रही है आपको तो यू शुड
गैब दैट। ठीक है? व्यूज तो Instagram
रील्स पे भी लोग अर्न कर लेते हैं।
YouTube पे भी श्स में अलग-अलग तरह के
थंबनेल्स यूज़ करके व्यूज ले लेते हैं।
लेकिन क्वालिटी नहीं होती ना। बट अगर
क्वालिटी भी मिल रही है कहीं पे व्यूज के
साथ-साथ। तो उसको गैब करो। चाहे वो कोई सा
भी डोमेन हो, किसी भी चैनल से मिल रहा हो,
कहीं से भी मिल रहा हो, उसको गैब करो। वह
बेस्ट लोग हैं। अगर मैं दे रहा हूं तो
डेफोनिक्स इज बेस्ट। कोई और दे रहा है तो
वह भी बेस्ट है। तो आपको गैब करना है।
फ्री में मिल रहा है इतना कुछ इधर-उधर सब
ले लो। सीखो लर्निंग स्किल्स गेन करो।
नॉलेज लो। नॉलेज और स्किल्स के बेसिस पे
ही जिंदगी चलती है। अदरवाइज जिंदगी कुछ
नहीं है। झंड है फिर जिंदगी। भाई सच में
बिना नॉलेज का लाइफ इज़ वस्ट। बिना स्किल
का लाइफ इज़ वस्ट। कोई कुछ नहीं कर पाएगा।
तो वो स्किल आपको लेनी है। राइट? हां जी
पीडीएफ जो आपको क्वेश्चंस और आंसर्स के जो
भी पीडीएफ हैं वो ग्रुप में एसओसी के
ग्रुप में शेयर हो जाएंगे। अगर नहीं जुड़े
हैं ग्रुप में तो हर एसओसी के क्लास के
वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में ग्रुप का लिंक
होता है ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा। ठीक है?
यू आर वेलकम अलबर
अल बिरूनी यू आर वेलकम
ओके थैंक्स शालिम थैंक्स शालिम थैंक्स
थैंक यू ब्रदर।
इतने खोज में बेस्ट टीचर मिल गया। अरे
धन्यवाद।
देखो कितनी क्लासेस आएंगी मैं तो यह खुद
नहीं बता सकता रुद्र क्योंकि मैंने कोई
मैं कोई पहले से प्लान करके नहीं चलता हूं
कि इतने महीने में मैं इतने क्लासेस करा
के खत्म कर दूंगा। जिस तरह से फ्लो चल
पाएगी और जिस तरीके से टॉपिक्स की
रिक्वायरमेंट होंगी मैं वैसे लेकर आऊंगा।
बट हां आई एम श्योर कि थ्री टू फोर मंथ्स
में मैं कोशिश करूंगा कि एल वन आपका आपका
कंप्लीट करके इंटरव्यू रेडी आपको फुल्ली
कर दूं और आप जाइए फिर इंटरव्यूज वगैरह
जॉब के लिए अप्लाई कीजिए एल1 के लिए और जब
जॉब लग जाए तो हमें बताइएगा जरूर
डेफ्रोनिक्स को टैग व कर दीजिएगा थोड़ा
lindin पे एक माहौल बना दीजिएगा मजा आ
जाएगा तो वो जो पोस्ट और जॉब वाली चीज देख
के मुझे जितनी खुशी होगी उतनी खुशी आपको
भी नहीं होगी। मैं लिटरली सही बता रहा
हूं। उतनी खुशी आपको भी नहीं होगी। आज के
टाइम में बग बंटी में जितने बंटीज के हॉल
ऑफ फेम के स्वैग्स के एप्रिसिएशंस मेल्स
जो हमारे लर्नर्स को आते हैं और वो टैग
करते हैं हमें तो उनको तो खुशी इस बात की
होती होगी कि उनको पैसा मिल रहा है। राइट?
उनको स्वैग मिल रहा है। उनको हॉल ऑफ फेम
मिल गया। इस बात की खुशी होती है। मुझे
होती है सेटिस्फेक्शन।
मुझे होती है एक खुशी। वैसी वाली जो
सेटिस्फैक्शन वाली खुशी होती है। वो खुशी
मिलती है। और सेटिस्फैक्शन वाली खुशी का
कोई भी कंपैरिजन नहीं होता है। ठीक है?
जैसे आप अपने घर पे जाते हो या पेरेंट्स
से बहुत दिनों बाद मिलते हो, अपने सिबलिंग
से मिलते हो, अपने बहुत क्लोज दोस्तों के
साथ कहीं जो जाते हो, वो जो सेटिस्फेक्शन
वाली खुशी मिलती है, वो खुशी मुझे मिलती
है। तो बग बंटी में बंटीज एंड हॉल फेम एंड
स्वैग से मिलती है मुझे। और यहां पे आपकी
जब जॉब लगेगी तो उसकी कोई कंपैरिजन नहीं
होगी। तो आई होप कि आप सब फॉलो करेंगे और
आप सब भी सिंसियर रहेंगे मेरे साथ-साथ।
राइट?
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके हाउ टू गेट क्या इंटर्नशिप इंटर्नशिप
के लिए भी अप्लाई कर सकते हैं यार आप जब
इसकी नॉलेज ले लेंगे तो आप आप चाहे तो
इंटर्नशिप के लिए भी अप्लाई कर सकते हैं।
नो इशज़ सेम जैसे जॉब के लिए अप्लाई
करेंगे। अप्लाई फॉर द इंटर्नशिप्स दैट्स
इट विद द नॉलेज।
या
श्योर श्योर श्योर ठीक है ठीक है
नहीं राज इन क्लासेस के अलावा एक्स्ट्रा
में आपको जो टॉपिक्स बोले जाते हैं
क्लासेस के दौरान कि ये टॉपिक्स हैं इनको
एक्सप्लोर कीजिए उन टॉपिक्स को एक्सप्लोर
कीजिए उसके अलावा ज्यादा कचरा मत पढ़िए
यहां वहां से होता क्या है देखो दिक्कतें
कई ऐसे स्टूडेंट्स के साथ लर्नर के साथ
आती है कि जैसे अब एसओसी की सीरीज यहां पे
चालू हुई है अब मैं आपको एक फ्लो में एक
पैटर्न में एक स्ट्रक्चर में सब चीजें बता
रहा हूं। अब कुछ स्टूडेंट्स या लर्नर्स
क्या करते हैं पता है? उनका माइंड इधर-उधर
घूमता है। तो मैंने बोला है एक्सप्लोर करो
टॉपिक्स को। तो एक्सप्लोर बस करके छोड़
देना है। अब उनका क्या है? अब 10 जगह से
एसओसी की वीडियोस देखना शुरू करेंगे। तो
वो कंफ्यूज होना शुरू करेंगे और कोई भी एक
चीज परफेक्ट नहीं हो पाएगी। तो आप सोर्स
ऑफ वो एक रखो। जब आप एक अच्छा प्रिपरेशन
कर लो। अच्छे से मास्टर कर लो। रेडी हो
जाओ। उसके बाद 10 जगह से देखो कोई फर्क
नहीं पड़ता। बट जब उस टाइम फ्रेम में
पैरेलली जब आप एक जगह से कर रहे हो तो आप
वहीं से उसी को फॉलो करो। कहीं से भी जो
भी कर रहे हो आप उसी को फॉलो करो। दैट्स
इट।
चलिए ओके गाइस। सो टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट पे आ
जाते हैं। अगेन एट टॉप 50 फैंस या अल
बिरूनी निशा चौधरी फोर स्कल विदु शेखर एम
एस हुसैन गीके एस रक्स कंचन चौधरी ओके
जगतगुरु स्वामी ललित मोहनदास मैं यंग
सिन्हा आदिकट आदित्य सिंह बृज खत्री
राम थारी कुमार ठीक है शैलेश
कश्मीरा आदित्य टेक डी ओके रितिक यादव
अल्टीमेट गेमिंग आदित्य सिंह सुजोई साह इस
लर्न स्किल
अमीला
पीबी एसजीआर कई लोग नए दिख रहे हैं आज
रोहित रुद्र शिवानी अ वेदांश शुभम उसके
बाद यश साक्षी टेकाय प्रिया
प्रियाल ओके या प्रिया अ पंकज शाहिलिम
रोहित हबीब बुल एगन देवांग गेमिंग ठीक है
दीपक मिस्टर रोबोट रिया डिविन मनीषांशु
राकेश प्रीतम सुजीत एंड लर्न साइलेंटली सो
दीज़ आर द टॉप फैंस लिस्ट एंड थैंक यू वेरी
मच फॉर बीइंग हियर इन द लिस्ट बिकॉज़ यू
गाइस आर सपोर्टिंग रियली रियली कंटिन्यू
कंटीन्यूअसली यू आर कमिंग एंड ऑल एवरीथिंग
सो इट्स अमेजिंग काफी अच्छा लगता है काफी
मजा आता है जब आप सपोर्ट एंड साथ में रहते
हैं तो आई होप कि आप सबको काफी कुछ सीखने
को जानने को मिल रहा है जो जो वीडियोस आती
हैं आपको अगर इंटरेस्टिंग लगती हैं तो आप
प्लीज इन वीडियोस को फैलाइए जरूर शेयर
जरूर कीजिए मैंने देखा कई लोगों को मैं
tlegram पे देखता हूं WhatsApp ग्रुप्स
में कुछ हूं वहां लोग शेयर करते हैं
वीडियोस को एक अच्छा लगता है आप हालांकि
आप नहीं समझ पाएंगे कि मैं कौन से नंबर से
और कहां से जुड़ा हूं उन ग्रुप्स में बट
स्टिल मुझे देख के काफी अच्छा लगता है कि
पीपल आर शेयरिंग एंड एक्चुअली शेयरिंग तो
प्लीज उसको कंटिन्यू कीजिए लोगों तक
पहुंचाइए इन वीडियोस को इन क्लासेस को
बहुत जरूरी है लोगों तक पहुंचना सिर्फ
अपने तक मत रखिए। मैं आपसे यही रिक्वेस्ट
करूंगा। अपने तक रखेंगे तो इट्स नॉट गुड।
इट्स नॉट फेयर। जितना नॉलेज को शेयर करते
हैं नॉलेज उतना ही आपका इंक्रीस होता है,
बढ़ता है। तो प्लीज शेयर द वीडियोस, लाइक
द वीडियोस। अगर आपको जो अच्छी लगती हो,
चैनल अगर फॉलो नहीं करा है, सब्सक्राइब
नहीं करा है तो सब्सक्राइब करके बेल आइकॉन
को प्रेस कर दिया कीजिएगा। ऑल नोटिफिकेशन
इनेबल कर दीजिएगा ताकि आपको नोटिफिकेशन
मिलती रहेगी। एंड जो भी अपडेट्स आएंगे
आपको मिल जाएगा। राइट? दैट्स ऑल फॉर नाउ
गाइज़ फॉर दिस सेशन। आज के सेशन को यहीं पे
समाप्त किया जाता है। एंड यहां पे पोल में
हमने डाला था। मजा आया तो यस 100% लोगों
को मजा आया। एंड दैट्स इंटरेस्टिंग। काफी
अच्छा लगा ये अ देख के। अ मिलते हैं। अ
अगेन गाइस बहुत जल्द नेक्स्ट क्लास में
200 कमेंट्स याद रखिएगा। एंड ये जो
रिसोर्सेज हैं आपके ग्रुप्स में शेयर हो
जाएंगे। सो सभी को टाटा बाय-बाय। गुड नाइट
एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में। थैंक यू
वेरी मच गाइस। नमस्ते।
लाइक ठोक के जाना जो भी जाना।
हां